The game is gone.
The game disappeared.
What a mystery, I think.
It's so quiet.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Howdy, howdy, howdy doody.
The first mystery that we must solve.
Oh my gosh, Katsu, happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Um, hold on, let me get...
Uh...
Konnan shiwa...
Nan shi doru...
Shama, hold on.
This is my center of operations, my desk.
Go ahead and poke around.
If you want to know the particulars of how I do what I do, take a look at the book titled How to Be a Detective.
It's really helpful, especially if you're new to the mystery-solving business.
And be sure to check out my scrapbook.
I put memorabilia from all my past cases in there.
A lot of them were pretty dangerous and at times really scary.
But don't say anything about that to my dad, okay?
Okay.
He worries about me enough as it is.
Dang, she's a yapper.
And whatever you do, read what's in the file called Case File.
Okay.
That'll tell you all about the mystery I'm about to try to solve.
If you think you're ready to dive into that mystery, just click on the plane ticket and you'll be on your way.
Okay.
Yay!
Katsu, let me sing your happy birthday before I forget.
Let's do it.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Katsu.
Happy birthday!
I have talked about wanting to play an MC Drew games before.
So...
Finally!
I thought this one would be fun to play because...
It's...
I think it's like kind of like a cringe kinono to have her be in Japan.
Thanks for haunting yesterday, Mita!
I got a doctor's appointment for my wrist.
Oh!
Good!
Good.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
It's what I'll say in November.
Oh.
So...
I can't...
It's kind of...
So if I exit out of the game...
Or if I tab out...
Hold on.
Uh...
Wait.
Hold on.
My brain is a little scrambled today.
Um...
If I...
Miss super chat...
I...
Have to...
Tab...
Out of game...
And I...
Miss...
Wait.
I...
Uh...
Oh...
I...
I might...
Miss...
Uh...
You guys!
It's not Tendi's birthday!
He said it's his birthday in November!
But also...
Happy early birthday!
Haun!
Happy early birthday.
Good luck with your appointment.
Okay.
Uh...
See, you can hear the game now.
You can hear the game, right?
Oh no!
I lost the chat!
Oh my gosh!
It's old game!
So it's kind of like...
And then...
You can see...
My cursor...
Is...
It...
It cannot escape.
Is someone mowing the lawn?
What is this?
Dad...
Dad simulator...
Oh yeah!
It's Saturday morning!
But anyway!
So yeah!
I wanted to...
Kind of...
I wanted to play...
The Nancy Drew game!
Just because I wanted to play one for...
For my own...
Silly reasons!
Cause whatever!
My mic sounds different!
Muffle?
It's literally the same mic I've been using!
It's the same mic I've been using!
Bit muted!
Really?
Did you mess around with settings?
For the ASMR?
Oh!
You know what?
Well...
Not on my...
I use a different mic...
Hold on...
Let me see...
Yesterday was my first ASMR experience...
It was actually really fun...
I hope you do more...
Thank you!
Hold on...
Let me try...
What's it called?
Let's try...
Does that sound better?
No...
Ah...
Oh, wait...
Does that sound...
Oh!
I think...
Ah, ah, ah...
Oh!
That does actually sound better!
Ah...
I think...
That sounds better...
Ah, ah, ah, ah...
It was just a different...
Preset...
How...
No...
My stuff is all messed up...
I didn't change any of the preset though...
That's so strange...
Mmm...
Hot dog!
That didn't change anything though...
Oh, the only thing I changed was...
Uh...
I had to like...
Do the stereo output...
But...
It shouldn't have changed anything else...
Maybe I accidentally did...
Oh, well...
We're fine now...
Ha, ha, ha...
Sounding better...
Sorry about that...
Isn't Nancy Drew an old people thing though?
What do you mean old people?
I did see some people being like...
Oh, this is my childhood...
Oh my god...
But I didn't play this game...
Oops...
Sorry...
That long ago...
Brother...
I've never played these games before...
I've only watched people play them...
Ha, ha, ha...
So...
This is...
This is new to me...
Also, I'm glad you fell asleep too...
The ASMR...
He, he, he...
I'm glad that it...
Um...
That it...
That it worked...
Thanks for the spooky number too...
He, he, he, he...
So happy I could see you again at Anime Ottawa...
Sorry for spilling my spaghetti...
Ha, ha, ha...
I also...
Didn't expect to be at Anime Ottawa...
Everything was so...
All over the place for me...
This weekend...
But...
Yeah...
Um...
Konnichiwa...
Nancy desu...
Yeah...
Wait, these games are older than 30?
No, they're not...
How...
Wait, when did this game come out?
Actually, I have no idea...
Let's see...
Nancy...
Drew...
N...
Nancy...
Drew...
Which one is this?
Shadow...
Arigato, arigato...
Chuuu...
Oh!
Wait, hold on...
Oh my gosh, sorry...
I keep having to...
Tab out...
I forgot to...
Make the notice not...
See through...
Ha, ha, ha...
Let me do this...
And this...
Okie dokie...
It's been two months since the jazz karaoke...
Won't ask for child support...
Just request you wish me happy birthday...
Brendan, happy birthday!
Why?
Um... I'm sorry, but if...
I don't think a baby is born in two months, okay?
The game is from 2010...
But it's the 23rd game!
It gives...
It does kind of give like an older vibe though, no?
Than 2010...
It's kind of like when you see Japanese videos from like 2006...
And you're like, wow, this looks like the 80s...
Ha, ha, ha...
But Brendan, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Brendan!
This seems way older than 2010...
Maybe they just kept the same...
Maybe they just never updated their graphics...
Let's see...
How to be a detective...
By Nancy Drew...
What's new?
As always, your mission is to solve the mystery...
By stepping into my shoes...
And deciding my every move...
Why is she saying that?
Oh please...
You may occasionally see a question mark...
In the upper right corner of the top mat...
If you click on it, it'll bring up a tip...
On how to manipulate the current puzzle...
Your cell phone has lots of features...
Phone, camera, clock, messages, and settings...
When you have a cell phone?
That's how you know it's not so old...
Each mode can be accessed...
By selecting its icon from the main menu...
Phone mode stores all the numbers you'll need to know...
I wanna be ninja-lady...
Scroll through to the name of the correct contact...
And press call...
Be sure to check in with Bess and George from time to time...
Tempo!
Nice!
It was happy to see you too...
Even though it was...
Through phone to phone!
But um...
What I also like about this game...
Is Nancy...
It's all like fully...
Narrated...
So I don't have to talk as much...
Which is great for my throat, baby!
What?
No...
Wait, what is this?
Use the options button in Contacts...
To go to the scrollable gallery of available images...
Camera mode allows you to take and view photos...
When in camera mode...
You can zoom in and pan...
Before taking a picture...
Click on view photos...
To see your saved photos...
Set your alarm to take a break...
And wake up hours later...
By entering clock mode...
Any text messages you receive...
Will show up in the messages mode...
Oh gosh...
I'm not paying attention at all...
And the settings menu...
To personalize the look of your phone...
By choosing one of the options...
In each drop down...
I'm not paying attention at all...
I'm sorry...
Who wants to be...
Who wants to...
How to Drop Manga 101...
Character B...
As their...
As their profile picture...
In my...
In my phone...
As of my contact...
Now that's early 2000s...
It's...
Oh my...
It's so good...
Oh my gosh...
So we got a camera...
We have an alarm...
And text messages...
Okay...
To get from one place to another in the game...
Just move your cursor around on the screen...
And click when an arrow pointing in the direction you want to go...
Appears...
An arrow pointing forward allows you to go forward...
While a back arrow allows you to step back...
Sometimes up and down arrows are available too...
Give it a try...
Find the forward arrow...
And check out Mr. Woogle Woggle...
He's my teddy bear...
Mr. Woogle...
Oh wait...
There it is...
When you want to turn around...
Move your cursor to the bottom of the screen...
Until it turns into an arrow that looks like a U-turn...
Or back arrow...
And click...
Where is it?
Up there...
Mr. Woogle Woggle...
She got nothing to say about him...
He's in pristine condition though...
If that were my bear...
His eyes would be ripped out...
His nose would be ripped out...
His arms would be ripped off...
His ears would be ripped off...
His legs would be ripped off...
His stomach would be exposed...
I always use my magnifying glass to scan my surroundings for clues...
When it turns red...
I know I'm on to something...
When your magnifying glass turns into a question mark...
You can talk to someone...
When it becomes a hand, you can use it to open and close things, pick up objects, and move things around.
To see how this works, move your mouse over this scene until the magnifying glass turns red.
Then click to zoom in.
See how the magnifying glass...
When you click on an object with a hand cursor...
To see what's in your inventory, just click on the inventory icon at the...
I keep reminders to myself in my journal.
Click on the notebook icon at the bottom left of the screen, and you'll see what I mean.
The gear icon allows you to determine how questioning suspects is something all detectives need to know how to do.
In the game, to get people to talk to you, all you have to do is click on them.
Skipper, skipper, skipper.
Before you can start playing, you need to decide whether to play as a junior or senior detective.
If you choose junior detective, you'll get more hints than you will if you're a senior detective.
And the puzzles will be a little easier.
When you're ready to start playing, just click on the plane tickets and hang on to your hat.
Thanks!
Thanks, Miss Nancy!
Senior detective!
What's this?
We got...
Utter pops.
Cream-filled lollipops.
Miss Nancy Drew!
Ummm!
Sorry!
Oh...
Coco C Laneicle!
Milk chocolate crunchies.
Yummy.
Crunchy.
Coco- Latte.
It's, very cow!
exaggeration,
Moons-chunk.
Out of this world shoots you snau- It's just a, It's a disk of cheese.
That's what she does.
Never mind, okay.
What's this one?
Licky-loo lollipops.
Thousands of flavors?
Why is she obsessed with cows?
Is this like Nancy Drew lore?
Oh my god, ma'am, stop slurping in my ear.
Raging infernos.
Fiery cinnamon balls.
Why is it all cow-related?
I don't know.
What's this?
A scrapbook.
Oh!
Wow!
Wait, so we're on the 14th game?
Sorry, we're on the 23rd game.
Let's see.
Wow.
This is a lot of stuff.
A student was found dead at the bottom of a flight of stairs at Paseo Del Mar High School, where my aunt Eloise... Eloise... Eloise was the librarian.
This was the one case I almost didn't survive.
Damn!
Case 2.
Stay tuned for danger.
Oh my god.
What is... The very first case.
She almost didn't survive.
I like this.
Corner diner.
School library.
Locker hall.
Study dome.
Even the dark, dank basement boiler room.
Wow.
As if living in the Big Apple wasn't exciting enough, I got to mingle with actors, agents, producers.
I even saved Rick...
Arlen's life.
Wow!
Looks like one of those free CD games you get out of a cereal box.
Case number three.
Message in a haunted mansion.
When it comes to ghosts?
I have never been much of a believer.
But I have to admit, this case made me wonder.
Rick Astley, maybe.
Number four.
Treasure in the Royal Tower.
I headed to Wickford Castle in Wisconsin, hoping to do a little skiing.
But a blizzard shut me and a handful of others in and kept everyone else out.
Uh-oh.
She hates me.
Case number five.
The final scene.
I wonder if they were going to make this the last Nancy Drew game.
And they're like, nope.
The last thing I expected when I agreed to go with a friend to the Palladium Theater in St. Louis was that she would vanish.
Oh my god!
That's kidnapping.
Secret of the Scarlet Hand.
Okay.
I found myself embroiled in a mystery involving art, antiquities, and subterfuge.
What is that?
Ghost dogs of Moon Lake?
What in the...
Uh...
Sherlock Holmes is this?
The case started innocently enough.
My friend Sally McDonald invited me out to the house she'd just bought on Moon Lake.
But the night before I arrived, a pack of dogs with glowing eyes showed up in the middle of the night, barking and snarling and trying to get into the house, which scared Sally so bad that she dropped everything and fled!
Hmm...
Twinkle dogs?
The haunted carousel?
Okay.
Talk about your wild rides.
Why did her handwriting change?
Maybe they thought it would be too difficult to read.
Danger on Deception Island.
Antarctica?
Wait, no.
Pacific Northwest.
Oh my gosh, there's an actual place in Antarctica called Deception Island where it's actually a... it's like an active volcano.
And you can dig into the snow and it will like... they used to... like there's a little research base there.
I don't think it's used anymore.
Because it's kind of dangerous.
But you can dig into the snow and like... it will start boiling.
Like you can make your own little bath in the snow.
It's kind of cool.
Yeah.
This one's way lamer.
Probably.
The Secret of Shadow Ranch.
Oh.
Wait, her handwriting's back.
Yay.
Yep.
Okay.
Ghost towns, cowboys, horses.
Rattlesnakes.
This case had everything.
I was supposed to be vacationing at Shadow Ranch in Arizona with Bess and George there.
And an uncle owned the place.
But soon after I arrived, this glowing horse appeared out of nowhere.
Curse of Blackmoor Manor.
Whoa.
This one looks wild.
What is going on here?
Secret of the old clock.
Okay.
Um, Nancy Drew goes back in time.
No internet.
No television.
Living in 1930 wasn't exactly a piece of cake.
That's for sure.
Nor was investigating the mysterious occurrences at an inn run by a friend of mine and her guardian.
What?
Why is it...
Did she actually go back in time?
The series is great.
Detective Mito on the case.
Yeah.
Last train to Blue Moon Canyon.
Okay.
Look at these guys.
Wow.
Look at all this...
Look at this cast of characters.
Tino.
Tino looks awfully sus.
My best egg.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Danger by design.
Oh, she went to Florence.
Oh, we, we.
The creature of Kapu Cave in Hawaii.
Nancy's been everywhere.
Where does she get the money for this?
Do people pay her for solving these cases?
The white wolf of Icicle Creek.
Legend of the Crystal Skull.
Wait.
Wait a second.
Indie?
Indiana Jones?
I haven't played these in a long time, but...
In case you can die from eating the wrong sandwich.
Wait, what?
The Phantom of Venice.
Oh.
There I was in Venice, Italy, working undercover, surrounded by canals, gondolas, and romance.
I was in Detective Heaven.
Unfortunately, a thief known as the Phantom.
Wait, it's a phantom thief?
Proved to be a little more elusive and a lot more dangerous than I had counted on.
Ooh.
Haunting of Castle Malloy.
Well, we're getting real international now.
This is Ireland.
Ransom of the Seven Ships!
Bahamas.
Warnings at Waverly Academy.
Okay.
The black cat is watching.
I like how they wrote this and then, like, did the claw marks, but, like, went around it.
Trail of the Twister.
This poor guy.
Give him a reshoot.
Give this guy...
This is the, like, worst picture ever of him.
Oh, and that's it.
Nice.
And here we are.
About to go to Japan.
Let's read our case file.
Or I think Nancy will read it for us.
After a string of tough mysteries, I've decided it's time to take a break to do a little sightseeing.
I'm taking PG Crowmeister up on his offer to send me to his favorite Ria-Con, or traditional inn, in Kyoto, Japan.
I'll spend the days teaching English, and my nights with Bess and George, exploring the sights, fashion, history, and nightlife of downtown Kyoto.
From what I hear, the inn I'm staying at is known as one of the scariest places in the city.
The Ria-Con.
I'm not sure why people say that.
I might have to poke around a little to see what's really going on at the Ria-Con-hie.
The Ria-Con.
Spank, thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
The Ria-Con.
Look, there's even a pachinko place right here.
Okay, nice.
The Ria-Con.
Is that it?
All right.
Are you guys ready?
What else is here?
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Oh.
I guess I'm a senior detective.
Ducky,
thanks for the first time.
So.
Wow.
So Japanese.
Take off your shoes, Nancy Drew.
Oh.
Okay.
She's really into that painting.
Oh.
Konnichiwa.
Hi.
I have a reservation under Nancy Drew.
Oh my god.
Do you believe me now?
Obasan, it only fell.
Obasan!
It did not.
You know better.
I'm very sorry.
She...
She's just a little upset.
She does not want her here.
Tell her to go.
Now.
What was that about?
Why is she upset?
Please.
Don't worry about that.
Here.
This is your room key.
Thank you.
Why do I hear like a security camera?
Okay.
We...
We just got here.
Nihongo jousu, Nancy Drew.
She didn't even try.
I literally wanted to hear her be like, Konnichiwa.
Otashiwa.
Ne...
Nancy Drew.
Deshi.
Uh...
Yowyaku ga arimasu.
Cool.
Room 24.
Spooky.
Thanks.
Your room is on the second floor.
I've already heard your back.
sent up.
Please.
My name's Miwako.
Come to me if there's anything you need.
Thank you.
Oh, it's...
What the hell is that?
That's the security camera I'm hearing.
Literally got lost for an hour on this game because I wasn't paying attention to my hotel number.
No.
Is that a robotic cat?
Yeah, Suki.
Isn't she the greatest?
Lentaro got her for me.
I've wanted my own pet cat for forever, but I can't have one at the ryokan.
Ryokan?
I came into work one day, and there she was, right next to the sweetest note from Lentaro.
No refund.
I've never seen a robotic cat before.
What does it do?
She's not on it.
She's Suki.
Oh.
It's okay.
She didn't mean it.
Actually, she doesn't really do much.
Mainly sits.
But...
Oh, wait.
I just learned something neat.
It's terrifying.
Suki, date.
Oh, it stands up too?
Oh, okay.
Now it's kind of cute.
Oh, that's great.
That's all I remember right now.
But she can do a lot more.
Japan.
I should figure out what the rest of the commands are, come to think of it.
Although, to be honest, it's a little more believable if she just does what she wants.
Fuck.
Hold on.
Let me...
I'm gonna also move this over just a tiny tad.
Oh.
Let's do this.
Just so that you guys can see everything.
I don't want to be blocking anything.
That should be good.
That should be better.
Okay.
This thing is...
I don't know if I like Suki.
I think Suki is a little...
I don't think I Suki-Suki.
I think I...
What in the FNAF?
Is that its teeth?
Or...
It's just a little...
I think if it was more robot and less realistic looking, it would be cuter.
Suki-Tate.
Your grandmother seemed very upset about the portrait.
Your grandmother seemed very upset about the portrait breaking.
I mean...
It's no big deal.
She thinks it's a bad sign that the portrait fell from the wall.
Why is that?
It's a very special portrait.
It's one of the two remaining images of my mother and it was taken shortly before...
It's one of my grandmother's favorite portraits.
She's trauma dumping on us.
Interesting.
One thing I love about Nancy Drew is she is the nosiest lady ever.
She's got to stick her butt in everything.
Like, clearly it's a sensitive subject.
And she's like, yeah, I just met you.
What happened?
Yeah, I'm not even friends with you.
What happened to your mother?
I shouldn't bother you with our problems, Nancy.
Please.
It is very nice outside.
A perfect time to relax and enjoy your surroundings.
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
What's our... Hi.
Hi.
What is a ryokan?
A ryokan is almost exactly like a hotel or a spa, but far more traditional.
This ryokan has been in my family for generations.
Passed down from mother to oldest daughter in order to preserve the traditional style, the food, the caretaking.
Every little detail is as it would have been generations ago.
How long has the ryokan been in your family?
A very long time.
My grandmother says it has been passed down since the early 1700s.
Wow.
So one day you'll pass this place on to your daughter?
That must be very nice.
I didn't know she has a daughter.
Well, I'm the younger daughter.
My older sister, Yumi, will be the one to take over the ryokan.
Oh.
My grandmother is offering a few classes in traditional arts.
She's in room 18 at the end of the hall.
Okay.
I'll let you get back to work.
See you later.
Bye.
Alright, what do we got here?
Doru-sama.
Williams-sama.
Schneider-sama.
Miura-sama.
Herman-sama.
Mint the disembodied cat head is giving me a bad trip.
It's just so awkward, right?
Nancy, please be careful.
There's too much broken glass.
My bad.
I'm just a nosy, nosy lady.
God.
So nosy.
Whoa.
Ooh.
Nancy, don't stick your hand in the fire.
Please don't hang anything up there.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm getting scolded.
Guys would love this place.
We're in Kyoto, Japan.
This is as authentic as it gets.
What else?
What else we got?
Anything else?
Hmm.
Oh, no.
We could leave without side.
Oh.
Hello?
Hello.
Nancy, you made it.
How was your ride?
It was pretty good.
We need to get Bessa.
I love Japan.
I have done so much shopping, and George's convention is crazy.
We need to give her a... a phone, a picture.
I've never seen so many people.
It's totally sold out.
You sound pretty excited.
Well, yeah.
Kinda hard not to be here.
I don't even know where to start.
Have you ever had mochi?
It's a revelation, Nancy.
I'm not even kidding.
And the shopping.
Conference me in already.
Mochi ice cream, yeah.
Okay.
Does that do it?
No?
Okay.
No, hit the...
No, the...
J-Rock.
You do it, then.
We all on?
Yes.
Yep.
Why is that so hard?
It so isn't.
Anyway, what's your story?
What are you up to?
You coming over?
I'm still getting settled in, but I'll be out to see you guys soon.
Everyone's so eccentric.
How's the...
Whatever it is you're staying at?
Reacon.
It's great.
A little strange, though.
When I was checking in, a picture fell off the wall, and everyone was really weird about it.
Huh.
Oh, no.
Our train's going to be here in a sec.
Gotta go.
See you, Nancy.
Bye.
Wait, if you guys were standing right next to each other, why didn't you just...
Why didn't you just...
Just have...
Talk together.
Instead of...
Paging...
Paging her in.
Alright, we got...
I need a dictionary to translate that.
Oh, no!
She's illiterate!
Do you know what the kanji says?
Kairos!
Thank you for the 20th!
Thank you so much!
Ryokan.
That's right!
Densha!
I'm guessing... I can't read the first kanji, but this is Kinshi, so it probably is like...
Probably like no traffic or like no... cars or whatever.
And then Kyoto...
What is this...
I need to translate that.
What is that, kian?
Which is no smoking.
No driving.
Yeah.
Will there be any cosplay girls at a RiaCon?
Yeah, the RiaCon.
Oh my gosh, we're at the RiaCon!
Wow!
I've always wanted...
Where are we?
I've always wanted to go!
Oh!
Oh, okay.
What's...
What?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What's in here?
Oh, this is...
Whoa.
Okay.
Uh...
O1.
Okay.
Blocked.
Damn, Nancy!
You can't just go into people's rooms!
Yeah, I hope so.
Blocked.
Damn, Nancy!
I need a key to open this door.
Yeah, it's not yours!
Locked.
We could go into the men's side of the...
Whoa!
Hang on!
Men only right now.
What do you mean?
The baths!
The blue banner means the baths are for men.
The red banner means women only.
This guy looks like an otaku.
I don't know why we don't mention this at the front desk.
This is useful information.
I agree.
Anyway, I'm Rentaro.
Oh!
I'm out in the garden if you need anything.
Thanks, Rentaro!
Oh!
Ow!
That hurt.
Hideo Kojima!
I'll have to wait until the banner changes color.
Damn.
Nancy, that never stopped you before.
Come on.
Locked.
Come on, girl.
Seriously?
Locked.
Hmm.
Ooh!
Garden!
Oh, I hear like the little deer scare.
Um...
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Back?
Wow, this is like so detailed, no?
Where's our room?
19...
Oh, we're close!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
We're not close.
Locked.
We're going the wrong way.
Oh, she said on the second floor.
No.
Hahaha!
Oh!
We went in a big ol' circle!
It's gonna take me a second, guys, to get rid- Where's the stairs, though?
What's this?
Famous Kyoto Gardens.
A visitor's guide.
Whoa!
Oh!
Um...
It's a lot of reading.
Thanks.
What is this music?
Hi.
I met Rentaro.
Who is he?
Oh, Rentaro.
He's my boyfriend.
He's also a handyman around here.
Boyfriend?
Have you two been dating long?
I'm sorry.
I should really get back to my paperwork.
But if you have any questions about the ryokan, please don't hesitate to ask.
How long have you been dating?
Nancy, don't ask questions.
Oh shit.
I'll talk to you later.
See you later.
Nancy, stop being so nosy!
Oh, here we go.
Locked.
Damn.
I need a key to open this door.
Nancy, we'll get in one of these.
Wait.
Locked.
They're going up.
Oh, shoot.
Locked.
Okay, I think it's on the other side.
So we go down here.
And we go through here.
And we go up here.
Locked.
22.
We're 24.
Maybe this one.
Yippee!
Locked.
Oh.
Alright.
What else do we have in here?
Oh, this is the case file.
Okay.
Are we gonna be able to play pachinko?
I wonder.
That'd be awesome.
What the hell is this?
No, what is that?
Okay.
Um.
Ooh, what's this?
Wow!
Small room.
I don't think...
The Japan Teacher Exchange.
No, wait, wait.
I...
I do...
She said that she was going to be...
Like, teaching English.
But...
I thought it was like a...
Oh, yeah.
Someone's just...
Hiring me.
This is actually like jet.
Oh, wait.
No, it's TE.
TE Japan.
I never thought spending a summer abroad would be so rewarding.
TE.
Japan was the best experience I could have asked for.
Duration.
Two weeks.
Three to four weeks.
Five to eight weeks.
Dear teacher.
Thank you for teaching us English.
You were the best teacher ever.
We'll miss you.
Your students from class...
Nine.
News.
TE Japan changed my life.
By the end of the program, I'd learned so much more than I'd ever dreamed.
Jamie.
Experience the excitement of living abroad and make a difference as a teacher's aide in Japan.
You'll team with a certain...
Oh, sorry.
Certified instructor to teach English to grade school children during the day.
Leaving your evenings free to explore and discover Japan.
I heard Nancy is retiring from solving crimes to become an artist.
What?
No, she couldn't.
Programs are available to visiting students during the summer months with 20 hours in the classroom per week.
Responsibilities include preparing lessons, grading, writing assignments, and helping the children practice their conversational skills.
Make a difference.
And new friends.
That will last a lifetime.
Black.
Kuro.
Cat.
Neko.
Red.
Aka.
You don't know how to...
You don't even know how to say those.
Nancy Drew.
You need a dictionary for the signs.
Our students.
Whoa!
We have Kenta.
Who likes dinosaurs?
Robots?
Playing tag with brothers and friends.
He's extremely...
Why are we getting all this stuff about our students?
He's a bit difficult to get focused.
Very helpful.
Can be given additional classroom chores and...
We're putting Kenta to work.
Fumiko.
Reading cats.
Cooking with her mom.
Very bright and self-reliant.
Would consider advancing her to next grade level, but socially is very reserved and somewhat delayed.
These are too...
These are too realistic, I'd say.
Oh my god.
Kenta rocks.
Yeah, we love Kenta.
He's so cool.
I mean...
She likes riding her bike.
Playing with her sister and friends.
Dolls and puzzles.
Deliberately split her and her twin sister into different classes.
As they were relying too much on each other.
With Kana taking charge and making decisions.
Aimi is starting to stand on her own, but may need additional encouragement.
Some difficulties with grammar.
Yeah, these are the suspects of the crime.
Sakura enjoys playing by the seaside cliffs.
Get the seven-year-old away from the cliffs.
Very interested in wells.
Are she okay?
Sakura is very quiet and prone to making cryptic statements that other children find disturbing.
There's something wrong about that Sakura chick.
She's not right.
Is she okay?
A self-directed learner.
She knows more about historic Japan than most.
Although she does seem overly fixated on some of the more morbid chapters of history.
Often needs to be redirected towards appropriate class discussion.
She kind of sounds like me when I was a kid.
Where I was just like morbidly...
Or I was obsessed with like the morbid things of...
Some kids are just like that.
I, you know...
I came out fine.
Takeo.
Likes marine animals visiting seashore with family.
One year busted!
Thank you!
Yeah, that kid ain't right.
Very distractible.
Seemingly intelli...
Seeming...
Seemingly intelligent.
He's seven!
Seven!
Loses everything and has yet to turn in an assignment on time.
Does excellent work when and if he remembers to hand it in.
Tends to get lost easily and is often late to class.
Those are our students!
Darja!
Thank you so much for your ear!
Thank you!
Am I...
Delayed?
Sorry.
I put on ultra low latency, but I feel like...
I feel like it's a little delayed.
That's okay.
What's your name?
Alright, let's grade some homework.
What?
We have...
Sakura.
I is Sakura.
No.
Bad.
Wait.
Sakura.
Oh, this is her.
We is Japanese.
No.
Um...
You know what?
I has black hair.
Already did that one.
Oh, my bad.
Okay.
Next.
Aimi.
My name is Aimi.
I are Japan.
I is seven.
My eyes is brown.
Oh, whoops.
The first one was good.
I already snapped that one.
Fumiko.
I am Fumiko.
I am Japanese.
I am seven.
I have black hair.
Damn.
Fumiko is a genius.
Wow.
My name is...
Whoa.
He's using apostrophes.
Mine's Japanese.
Seven I am.
Eyes be brown.
Oh, no.
Kenta is so awesome.
Yeah, Kenta.
Kenta's great.
Takeo.
I name is Takeo.
I is ten.
I is Japanese.
I have blue hair.
Cool.
Um, I think there's a ghost behind us.
Sorry, Takeo.
Okay.
We graded.
What's this?
Ryokan Hie?
If I have something to send, this might come in handy.
Neat.
Welcome to Ryokan Hie.
Oh, no.
Not the papyrus one.
Where you will experience traditional Japanese culture and hospitality at its finest.
Located near the base of majestic Mount Hie, our Ryokan has been offering a relaxing stay to guests since the 1700s.
Hi, ghost.
Hello.
Ease away.
The day travels with a calming soak in the hot springs bath.
The entrance is located on the first floor hallway across from room number seven, with open times changing daily for men and women.
Showers for pre-washing and towels are available in the baths.
Hi.
Oh my gosh.
I was just thinking the other day how I wanted to go.
I've only stayed at Ryokan once.
There was a drama called Good Morning Call.
And I really liked it.
And I was watching it while I was in Japan.
And so there's one episode where they go to Ikaho Onsen, which is in Gunma.
Which is like a little north of Tokyo.
And so I went to Ikaho Onsen for just like a day.
I went for like a... it was like a weekend trip.
And I took... I did like Oshikatsu at the places that they filmed at.
Yeah.
I've actually never been to Kyoto.
But right now I don't really want to go because...
Right now all I hear about it is that it's so overly crowded with tourists.
So...
I don't know.
I don't know if like...
One, I don't want to contribute to that.
And two...
I...
Don't want to go with a lot of people.
Yeah, they're not really happy with foreigners right now.
Yeah...
I think it's just like the...
Over...
Crowding...
Of stuff.
Like...
People who are living in Kyoto are having trouble...
Being able to get to places they need to.
Because like trains and everything is so crowded.
Hmm...
I went during February and it wasn't bad.
I think it's only a recent thing that happened, no?
But like...
Maybe not.
Because there was...
What, like last year they were saying they were like...
Closing off certain streets to for...
To...
To foreigners.
Because they were like chasing after the...
The...
The Maiko and everything.
Uh...
So...
But you know...
If you go, just be respectful.
Mm-hmm.
I mean that's...
That should be all the time though.
For guests wishing...
To...
Visit more of Kyoto.
The local...
Misawa station offers...
Real access to downtown.
Popular tourist sites always include the...
Pachinko Parlor!
Hey!
Why don't you gamble while you're at Kyoto?
So happy you're streaming a Nancy-Ju game!
Thank you, counselor!
Thank you.
Um...
At the Kurei...
At...
Or...
Sorry.
At Kurei?
Or the Exposition Center.
Currently hosting the Technology of Tomorrow Ex...
Expo at...
Uh...
Matsuei.
It is...
Suggested that guests pre-purchase their FASCA...
FASCA train tickets before...
Arriving at the Ryokan.
Our front desk is open from...
7am, 1am daily...
To help with any additional needs.
Thank you for choosing Ryokan Hiei.
Welcome home!
Alright, let's go to Pachinko, baby.
What else is in our room?
Um...
Oh!
That's our stuff!
We got our phrase book!
What's...
Wait, I need to know...
Can I use it?
Maybe not.
Okay.
We've got...
All the candies and stuff that we...
Oh!
There's our FASCA!
Our train pass...
I guess that's everything.
Very nice.
Anything in here?
Nope.
I like that we just brought candy.
There's no food in Japan.
Okay...
Our...
One...
A star!
Interesting.
Let's check out our view.
Just kidding.
Nevermind.
Wasn't there a table?
Oh, here.
Um...
Okay.
I guess we did everything in the room.
No?
Seems like it.
Mmm...
She can't get the cow snacks.
True!
The music is so spooky.
Still for men only.
Let's go to the gardens.
Do, do, do, do,
do, do, do, do, do.
Wow, how...
I'm feeling so relaxed.
It's so peaceful.
Yup.
I'm feeling so relaxed right now.
Oh, God.
So scary.
I'm feeling so relaxed!
Oh, hello!
Hi again.
I'm Rentaro.
It's nice to meet you officially.
So, um...
You're still here.
That's surprising.
I'm Nancy.
What do you mean, surprising?
Did I say that?
Whoops!
So, you're American.
From New York City?
No, a place called River Heights.
It's in...
Oh, okay.
Oh, he doesn't care.
That's one of the places I always wanted to go.
I mean, you'd have to be crazy to live there.
But on the other hand, you'd have to be crazy not to live there.
It's one of those, um...
This accent.
Unwinnables.
Do you work here?
Technically.
It's a complicated thing we've got going on.
I'm sort of like the handyman around here.
Okay.
So, should I bother getting to know you, or are you going to be like all of the rest?
What do all of the rest do?
He's so cryptic.
Get spooked in the middle of the night, pack their bags and never come back.
Even the ones who come to see the ghosts.
I shouldn't be telling you this.
Oh, well, already did.
If you see Takaido, this conversation never happened.
Ghosts?
What ghosts?
We got one of those, um, haunted hotspot guides.
So we get a lot of ghost hunters here.
And that's always a treat, because they're totally not obnoxious.
So, people think this place is haunted?
Uh-huh.
Well, some people think this place is haunted.
Kind of like some people think the moon landing was faked.
And some people like adult contemporary.
Don't be one of those people.
He's so judgy.
You like puzzles?
I guess you could say that.
I figured...
Wait.
You're going to love this.
A nonogram?
It's called a nonogram.
Wait, that's my thing.
What's that?
It's just another example of how awesome numbers are.
I do those every day.
The letters are cool and all.
He looks like young Hideo Koji.
I mean, get with the game letters.
He really does.
Numbers on the other hand.
Uh-huh.
Get a few handfuls of those.
And you can make a bridge.
Or send a person into space.
Or express the makeup of our genetic code.
Or...
They can make a neat picture.
Okay.
Take a look in here.
All you need to do...
I love nonograms.
...is look this over and finish the pattern.
And when you're done, picture!
Here, take this.
Give it a shot.
Bring it back when you're done, and I'll give you something better.
Ooh.
Sure.
And there are instructions inside in case you get stuck.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll stop.
Uh, wait.
Actually, let's...
Miwako seems to really like Suki.
I know.
Which is great.
She's Suki Suki.
Because that girl is hard to buy for.
And it's been sort of like...
I thought he said he's...
She's hot.
Either she's getting crazy sensitive, or I'm becoming a huge jerk.
Hmm.
Give it a shot.
Oh, I will.
It's definitely one or both of those things.
Okay.
Um, what are you...
What are you building there, mister?
What are you building there?
Oh.
This is the Rentaro 4000.
I sort of got inspired by Suki.
What's it going to be?
A robotic dog.
Oh.
Or maybe just a robotic dog's leg.
Leg?
I'll be honest, I had no idea how wrong these things take to build.
But then again, a dog's leg is not a good gift without the rest of the dog.
So the borders aren't creepy, come to think of it.
Yeah.
Is it going to be a gift for Miwako?
Oh, definitely.
She's my robotic muse.
But she's not robotic.
Not that you'd think she is.
And this is why I work with machines.
They're totally oblivious to awkwardness.
This poor guy.
Maybe Kenta can help.
This guy.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Rentaro?
I'll let you get back to work.
Bye.
What?
I don't even know what she's talking about.
What is he working on?
Okay, hold on.
The puzzle book.
Nonograms!
I love...
I don't need the instructions.
Okay.
Uh...
Oops.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Wait, it's...
It's 5x5.
So...
Uh...
Wait.
Oh, it's 10.
Oh, I'm thinking of 15.
Uh...
But we can...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
But we can do this.
We can do that.
We can do this.
Uh...
That...
I wish you could mark out the ones that you don't use.
No?
Um...
Usually, with these, like, you can...
You can, like, cross out, you know?
Yeah!
Picross is a nonogram.
Mm-hmm.
So...
Yeah.
So that's that.
Oh, and that's that.
And this...
So that.
And then this.
And...
That.
So this, and this.
One, two, three, four, six, seven...
Uh...
It's hard when you can't cross out!
No!
So that's two.
And then four...
Is it a heart?
Maybe?
Probably.
It's a heart.
Probably?
Like, it's probably this.
If I had to guess.
It's probably just this.
For the dog's nose.
Oh, maybe!
Is there more?
Did I complete it?
How do I know?
Maybe I didn't do it right.
Oh, wait!
Oh, I just realized the four down here.
I did it!
Oh, there we go.
That's why.
Is there more?
Nancy?
Oop.
Give me more puzzle!
No!
I missed...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I don't know why, but it seems like my chat is a little delayed.
Upper right?
No, it doesn't do anything.
Oh my god, the music is insane!
What about...
Renogram?
Oh, never mind.
I've finished your puzzle!
Hello?
I've finished the Nanograms puzzle.
Awesome!
Nice job!
What do you think?
I...
What if I say...
I've got something better.
You know it.
You love it.
The original!
Sudoku!
It's so crazy.
Oh, I've played that before.
Great!
Eh!
I've got some good ones for you here.
Here you go.
Bring it back if you want more.
Thanks!
I'm back for more Nanograms!
Nano!
Here you go!
Thank you!
I'll stop bugging you now.
Catch you around!
Bye!
Okay, let's do more Nanograms.
Ah!
Yeah!
Okay...
Oop!
3...
1, 1, 1, 2, 3...
2...
So this one's solved.
This one's solved.
He is really ganky.
6...
Oh gosh, I hate not being able to...
So...
I hate not being able to cross him out.
It's...
It's on hard mode right now.
Um...
3...
2...
I've never played this before.
Is it p-cross?
Yeah!
And p-crosses are just...
Or p-cross is just a nonogram.
So...
Basically, yeah.
It shows how to put an X, it does.
Am I stupid?
You can mark out known blanks with an X.
How?
How do I do that?
Wait, in the column with 2, 1...
Oh?
It doesn't tell me how!
But...
What do I click?
With my brain?
Click the square again?
Right click?
It was a right click this whole time!
Wow.
No more hard mode.
Thank goodness.
Oh wait, I think I was right earlier.
I'm silly.
Okay.
2...
1...
3...
See, just like that.
And then this...
And so...
Oh, okay.
I should probably explain how the game works.
So...
You have...
Your...
Your columns...
And your rows.
This will say...
What is filled in.
So, we have...
We have a...
5 by 5.
So...
Or...
Wait...
Is it 5 by 5?
Anyway, there's 10 slots.
So, this says 10.
You fill them all in.
And then...
With this...
It's 3, 1, 1.
But...
They can't touch.
So, it's 1, 1...
And then 1, 2, 3...
Oh!
It's gonna be like that.
And then either these two will make up the 3, or these two.
10 by 10.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Cause this is 5.
Sorry, my brain is low today.
But see here?
It's 1, 1, 1, 1.
So, it'll be 1.
We have 1 here, and 1 here.
And then...
These...
One of these will be 1.
And another 1.
So, we have 4.
It can't be this one.
Because this is...
It's just the...
The 1.
So, we do that.
So, that's 5.
And then 1 here.
So, it's that.
Yeah.
I do these literally daily, you guys.
Like, I am always...
And then...
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
We got the 2.
Um...
1, 2, 3...
1...
Let's see.
Mmm...
I'm slow today, though.
Uh...
So, this would be 1.
And then 2.
And then 1.
Like that.
And then this is 1.
So...
This is also 1.
Wait.
1, 2, 3...
1...
2, 3...
Oh, so like this.
Like that.
So, it can't be that.
Mmm...
Uh...
They're...
They're so fun, though.
So...
See, like, this is 1, 1, 1.
The reason it's this is because you can't have 3 1's here.
Because there always has to be a space.
In between them.
So, that's why we know that one is 1.
And that clears that row.
And then this clears that row.
Opening Meow Tower right now!
Oh, I love Meow Tower!
I play Meow...
That's what I play every day, is Meow Tower.
Hahaha.
So dissonate.
Does not...
Does not dissonate.
Uh...
And so...
Let's see.
Um...
So this is gonna be 3.
Like that.
So then we know that.
And then we know that.
See?
It's all just...
And that clears that row.
It's just all about...
You get it...
Just one step at a time.
So we have the 1, 1.
So we know that.
So that clears that row.
And that clears that row.
There in this.
1, 2, 3.
That clears that...
Oops.
That clears that row.
This.
Another one down.
Easy.
What is that?
A snail?
What is it?
A crashing wave?
Oh, maybe.
I don't know how to play Sudoku, though.
I mean, I know.
I know, but I don't know.
See, like, that can't be two.
Two, so it would be...
It can't be four.
Six, maybe?
Can't be six.
Is it nine?
I don't understand Sudoku, though.
Oh, I don't see who raided me, but thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just slower at Sudoku.
Because I don't ever play Sudoku.
But I know how to play.
But I just don't know.
Right box bid is won.
Thanks, Nicholas.
Oh, Nyaru!
Thank you for the raid.
We're playing Nancy Drew, but right now I'm distracted by the nonograms.
I'm back for more nonograms.
Here you go.
Thanks!
I'll stop bugging you now.
Got you around.
And, Rebac, thank you so much for the gift in.
Thank you, guys.
More nonograms.
I love nonograms.
Oh!
I love 15 by 15, though.
They're my favorite.
So, it'll be like this.
15...
Oh, whoa.
My bad, sorry.
I got too excited.
I'm too excitable.
I'm way too excitable.
Oh, thank goodness.
Okay.
Uh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hmm.
Uh.
I'm just getting all the obvious things out of the way real quick.
13.
With this.
Oh, so we have that.
Nice.
There.
Wait.
1, 2, 3.
4, 5, 6.
7, 8, 9.
10, 11, 12.
Yep.
Okay.
8.
And then there's 4.
Oh.
Whoops.
Uh.
So that's 1.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
4, 6.
7, 9.
10, 11.
So it's like that.
See?
Um.
Like that.
And then 4.
Oh!
Whoopsie.
Heh heh heh.
Um.
4 here.
What?
um...ok.
Like that... Like that...
Like that and that and that and that.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Like that.
Okay.
Feels like pressure.
Oh yeah, I can get rid of that.
That.
And that.
Yes.
Like that.
Three.
Two.
There.
Oh.
Uh.
Sorry, I really like these, you guys.
I really like nonograms, okay?
I'm sorry, I can't stop.
Once I start.
That's done.
That's that.
Wait a second.
I messed up!
I messed up somewhere.
No!
Wait!
Oh no, I messed up somewhere!
Wait, where did I mess up?
Where do you hear frogs?
Why are you guys saying frog?
Where did I mess up?
1, 2, 3, 4, 6, 5, 9, 11, 12.
Oh!
There.
That should be that.
Like that.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you!
There.
1, 2, 3.
Wait, nope.
There.
What about it?
Where am I missing?
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's a frog!
Where did I mess up?
I think I went too fast and my brain is too slow today.
Eww, 5, 1, 1, 1, 5, 1, 2, 3, 4, 6, 3, 4, 9, 1.
Where did I mess up?
No puzzle stands a chance.
I got it.
Yay!
I never noticed what I'm creating until I'm done with it.
I'm always just looking at the numbers.
Can I do one more?
Hello?
I'm back for more nonograms.
Here you go.
Thank you!
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Peace out.
Hold on, you guys froze again.
Go for it!
I love a nonogram.
I love the nonogram.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
One more.
Sorry.
Then we'll continue the game.
Just one more.
Okay.
I don't think I would...
This would be impossible if I couldn't cross him out though.
I...
Mm-mm.
Shh.
Oh, I...
Uh...
There we go.
Can't be that.
Let's see.
Right?
Yes.
I think.
I feel pressure though.
One, two, three, four.
One, two.
I feel pressure.
Just break out a web browser or hand cam.
What, for this?
Oh, finally some relaxing music.
Gosh.
Never mind.
I lied.
You're very cute when you're excited about doing them.
No!
That should be right.
I think.
I miss Meow Tower.
It's way easier.
Meow Tower.
The music is like just almost creepy.
Oh god.
It's getting creepier.
Okay.
Let's see.
What could this be?
Meow Tower.
Can't be that.
So that's that.
That.
Meow Meow Meow.
One, two, three, four, five.
Hmm.
Oh!
Sometimes my hand moves too fast.
Three, four, five, six.
Okay.
We're good there.
We're good, good, good there.
Uh, this.
Okay.
So that is not that.
Uh, that.
That.
And there.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Two.
This one's not so bad, I suppose.
You got this easy, cutie.
Thank you!
Yeah.
I am locked in.
I really like a nonogram though.
They're so fun.
And, you know, and they're just, you know...
I am locked.
We're... five, two.
And then two...
Two.
Okay and two.
Okay.
Mama not you not you not you not you.
Oh wait, it could be you... but you and you, what is it making?
You guys can't tell yet?
Oh wait, it is not.
I can't... Lollipop?
Magnifying glass?
Ahhh... maybe... maybe...
I think you guys weren't right.
I wish I would tell you.
It just makes you...
Assume, I suppose.
Let's see, we have five here.
Two, three, four there.
Alright, that's complete.
And you.
And...
Three, and... wait.
Oh, is it gonna be a question mark?
Probably, right?
It'll probably be a question mark in the middle.
That's kinda cute.
Like, if it's like that...
I'm... I'm guessing.
Don't wanna get ahead of myself.
I'm almost positive it's a question mark.
Wait, oh... like that?
Take that, puzzle.
You're solved.
Yeah!
Okay, that's the last one I'll do.
For now.
Back through my relaxing walk through the gardens.
Where are we?
Oh,
wait up.
What does it want me to do?
Where does it want me to go?
Oh, let's go talk to the lady.
What's going on?
I should listen in.
You are so nosy.
The strange sounds.
On the pounding.
On the screaming.
At all hours of the night.
Waking up my family.
Scaring the children half to death.
If you ask me, this rear can needs to be closed down.
Immediately.
I'm...
Very sorry.
Sorry change is nothing.
This is unacceptable.
I want my money back.
And I want a car sent immediately.
What is the accent?
She's German.
I think.
Pretty sure.
Who?
Uh...
I didn't mean to listen in, but um...
Oh damn!
All the names are gone except us and Williams.
Sama.
Williams-sama.
Um...
Are you okay?
Oh.
Hello, Nancy-san.
That guest seemed pretty upset.
Nancy-san.
Oh, it's nothing to worry about.
Trust me.
I see a lot at this desk and one thing never changes.
Is...
Travel is disorienting.
It's so very easy to get upset when you are far from home.
That's why we try to make things as comfortable as possible.
Um...
Uh...
What has been scaring the guests away?
Yeah.
Nothing.
They're not scared.
It's...
Something else.
Can I help you with anything?
I...
I heard what she said.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Okay.
See ya.
Matane.
Okay.
Can I leave?
Can I go to Pachinko?
Oh, wait.
I need a dictionary to translate that.
I have it.
A phrase book.
Oh!
Si!
Tran.
We're going to...
Nagoya?
Wait a second.
That's like kind of far.
Wait.
Misawa?
What?
Oh, I don't think this is accurate.
Wait a second.
I don't think this is accurate.
We're in Kyoto.
We're going to...
Omiya!
Wait.
Narita is...
Nara is...
Wait.
I don't think this is accurate.
Chiba is south.
Is Sendai is south too?
Um...
I don't think...
How is Kyoto east of Tokyo?
No.
It's...
Where is...
No.
Because we are here.
This is...
This would be...
Right...
Right-ish.
But...
Well...
That it's west.
It's west.
But...
I do...
Um...
This is...
Actually, when people say...
Don't be scared of the train system in Japan.
It's not that complicated.
This is not giving anybody...
Look!
Osaka is all the way over here!
What?
This is not giving anybody...
Any hope that it's...
Better.
Map not to scale.
Osaka all the way here.
Yep.
Alright.
We know where we're going.
To Nagoya!
Otsu!
Otsu Mintau!
Can I leave?
Can I go explore?
Can I get out of here?
I guess we're going to Otsu.
Why?
What's here?
What is at this place?
Why is...
This is like a really...
A rundown looking station.
It looks like New York.
Oh!
Wait!
We're just casually going to Tokyo.
What?
Ow!
Boy!
Okay.
Where should we go?
We could go...
Where are we going?
Let's just go to Tokyo, baby.
Wait.
I can't leave.
I can't even go to Tokyo.
Why not?
Um...
Naro?
Akita?
Am I...
Is this a...
Where am I supposed to go?
Is the question.
I feel.
What is like the...
And Draco, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
This is the maze puzzle.
Oh my god.
No way.
I mean, it's not really a puzzle though.
I just need to know where to get to.
Yeah, what's the goal?
Um...
Let's see.
Maybe...
Nope.
Never mind.
Sorry.
Wrong book.
Uh...
Rio-con room.
Yeah, we're so far from Kyoto now.
Is this butterfly?
Ay, ay, ay.
Uh...
Bess, where are you?
Whoa.
Uh...
Wait.
Kurei Station.
Okay, kurei...
Kurei...
This map is making me crazy.
Oh, here, here, here, here.
Okay, okay.
So, we are at Akita.
We can go... Let's see.
What would be the easiest way, I suppose?
We could go around on the green line.
Oli desu.
Crazy Oli.
I was watching her on... On, um... Michi's 3D debut.
We took the train from Kyoto to Hokkaido.
It's fine.
Yeah, obviously.
Yeah, where this is the best train ever.
I think we could go to... Wait, hold on.
Oh, the... I think... Oh, the... Yeah, okay.
It shows only two stops per station that intersects.
So... We could go up to Nara and then Sayo.
And then go down to... Uji.
Okay, all right.
Nara... Wait.
What did I just say?
We were going... Nara?
Nara, then Sayo.
Then Fuji.
Oh, gee.
All these stations look really similar.
Then Izumo.
Oh, no!
I just noticed it's...
Okay, I'm stupid.
I even said...
Each one only has two lines that it goes to.
I thought...
Did you hear Hikari and Nozomi...
Not even a little bit.
They're so easy.
Yay!
Pachinko!
And ramen...
Let's see.
Where can we go to?
Only to Pachinko.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Fun, love, smile, boom, koala!
Shudder, clunker.
Printed, tada.
Oh!
Koala.
Naito.
.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
A little girl.
Okay.
What are the devs kids?
Maybe?
Oh my god.
The photo is printed.
Ew.
Let's try again, Nancy.
Out of order!
Book was printed?
What the hell is my background?
Wait, what the hell?
What do I have on here?
Oh, one out of 30.
Okay.
Can I try again?
Connect phone, choose photos, press print.
Oh, it doesn't work.
My eyes.
God, this is so funny.
And my other favorite part about it is the plane that's carrying a flag that just says bird.
Oh.
Bird.
Let me out of here, Nancy Drew.
Alright.
Oh, we got the vending machine.
Ooh.
Exchange.
This is so dead in here.
It's also so quiet.
Here we go.
I need to find a card first before I can play Pachinko.
What do you mean a card?
That Yurei comic looks interesting.
I should check it out.
A Yurei comic?
What do you mean by that?
Wait, which one?
This?
Wait, I want the Yurei comic.
I'd like to see what the comic has to say about hauntings.
Me too!
I would love to hear that.
Wait, where do we get a card at, Nancy Drew?
Where?
No.
A card.
Where do we get it?
Left side of the door?
I tried clicking that.
Oh yeah, hold on.
Oh gosh, sometimes turning around is such a pain in the butt.
No, please!
Yeah, see here, it won't let you do anything.
So we came all the way here for nothing?
Oh my god.
Yurei, what does it mean?
Ghost.
Well, unless you're asking, like, I don't know.
Okay, we'll go the yellow line.
To Ube.
Yellow line to Ube.
So we go Izumo.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, we can't?
Oh, Izumo is...
Oh, dang it.
I did it again.
Wait, we can go to Sakai.
Sakai.
The most lively Japan has ever been.
Two Yuri haunting comics, please.
One for me and one for Nancy Drew.
We go to...
Ube.
Yurei.
No Amito.
Amito.
And then...
To...
Oh, more?
From Aomori?
Then from Aomori...
We can go to...
Uh...
Nagoya?
And Misawa.
Dang, what a...
What a waste of our time.
We've wasted, like, two weeks on this trip.
Hahaha!
Our children!
They're like, when is...
When is...
When is Drew-sama coming back...
To grade our papers?
Hahaha!
Okay.
Awesome.
Uh...
What do I do?
Hey, mister.
What's going on at this place?
Oh, do you believe that the Ryokan is haunted?
Do you believe that the Ryokan is haunted?
Sorry, the Ryokan.
I don't believe that anything is haunted.
Gasp!
Ghosts, uh...
Are just what happens when guilty people let their imaginations run wild.
What do you mean?
Think about it.
Why do ghosts always want revenge?
They're what people invent when they feel guilty.
If that wasn't the case, then ghosts would want all sorts of things.
But no, they always want revenge.
I'm back for more nonograms!
Hahaha!
Oh wait, he's got the portrait from the lobby.
Is that the portrait from the lobby?
Yeah.
I'm reframing it.
Although it's way harder to do than I thought it would be.
It's got a really strange backing.
I'm guilty.
Would you like some help?
Have at it!
I mean, I do want revenge, but...
This thing is officially making me nuts!
The tools you'll need are neither frame.
Okay, now I'm a professional restorer.
Okay.
It looks like I need to find a way to make sure none of the wires are crossing.
Oh.
Sorry, Nancy Drew.
Need someone to do nonograms and travel on trains non-stop?
Nancy Drew is on the case!
Mint is real to me.
I'm real!
I'm real, I promise.
Revengeance.
Oh, okay.
I can just place them anywhere, it seems.
Oh, golly.
What the hell?
How am I supposed to make them knock?
None of them...
Wait, wait.
None of them cross?
Impossible.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe I shouldn't have chosen senior citizen.
Oh, now the creepy music is back.
Impossible.
Oh, dang.
I was gonna say, those aren't crossing, but they are.
Maybe like that.
It's getting a little less webby.
Wouldn't you want them to cross?
What?
Who created this contraption?
What kind of...
Sadistic...
Creature?
Senior investigator.
Senior citizen.
This guy's hard too, cause he's like connected to all...
Four that I have in the corner.
Maybe I shouldn't put them in the corner.
I don't know.
Holy moly.
You're just a figment of my guilty conscience.
Wow.
What are you guilty of?
Huh?
Move them inwards.
These ones?
Oh my gosh.
I feel even more lost than before.
What's like a hint for this?
I don't want to use her tips.
She'll cost me.
She'll charge me.
She'll be like...
One hint is one dollar.
You guys wouldn't charge me.
I got no clue.
Can they overlap...
The buttons?
Doesn't seem like it.
If we'd charge two...
Put the ones with a lot of connections in the middle and put direct connections right on...
Next to each other.
Wait, so like this in the middle?
This in the middle?
This...
Can they cross themselves?
This one in the middle?
Okay.
Direct...
Next to each other.
But this one is connected to so many.
It looks just as bad as it did when I first started.
More like Nancy screwed on my right.
Damn!
Nancy Drew, I'm too dumb for this!
Okay, RZ, thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
Oh...
See like these...
This...
Maybe...
Over here...
Oh...
Oh gosh...
I can't tell where anything needs to go!
Ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha...
Maybe I'll put these over here.
This...
I
don't know where to place these little buttons on the board.
I don't know what to do.
Someone help me!
Why does it look like the stick bug?
It does.
The hell...
What the hell...
Okay, where's our hint?
Oh, because I play...
I don't need a task list because I'm playing as a senior!
Oh, I shouldn't have played as a senior detective.
Oh...
Check!
Where's my hints?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait...
Uh...
Quick, exit, exit.
Where's my hints?
That's the truth!
Use the direct connections to make an outer circle, then work inward.
Direct connections like this...
And this...
And...
Like what I...
Like, kind of what I have?
Okay...
So...
This...
Maybe here...
Right?
And then...
Like that...
Okay...
Make a circle...
Oh, see, this one's hard!
Because I have them on the opposite side!
Okay, hold on...
Make a circle...
See, this looks so clean now...
Or cleaner...
Kind of...
More like senior citizen...
That's what I said!
Ugh...
Okay...
Okay, this...
This...
This is all good!
Okay, hold on...
I'm gonna scoot it...
Scoot...
Scoot it over a little...
Oh wait, it's not all good!
There's this guy here...
Ugh...
We're getting close!
Ish...
Eeeee...
Agh...
Lois went up...
This one?
I'm not done...
I'm having...
I want to touch this area real quick...
Not yet...
This guy is also...
A pain in my...
Side...
Oh...
It looks so clean...
And then you notice...
That it's like...
Not...
No...
Like you...
Oh my god!
What?
This is so...
Seeing even here!
Oh no...
Eeeee...
Like here looks good...
Until you see this...
Sometimes it looks so clean...
That I...
It...
I don't feel like it...
Like...
Look...
It looks like almost...
It should be fine...
But then I'm like...
Wait a second...
This is not fine...
I have no stinking idea...
On the other side...
Pull the top...
Middle...
Down...
Below the line...
This...
What line...
What are you talking about?
This...
Lower all the nodes...
On the right side...
To fix the middle connections...
Huh...
It doesn't fix anything...
Because this doesn't work.
And this doesn't work.
This doesn't work.
This is so, actually so tricky.
Topmost to the far left.
That doesn't... sorry, that doesn't help me.
Pray for me.
Welcome to Bad Pusha.
Thank you.
I wish I was playing no-no-grams right now.
Can I go back to no-no-grams, please?
I want more no-no-grams, please.
It doesn't work.
I don't even know how to focus.
It's like...
I don't even know how to position them to make it...
Like, that's where...
I don't even know...
How...
To even... Like, what to focus on...
To make it work!
Bring internal crosses...
Wait, bring internal with crosses to the outside.
So, like that.
But then there's a cross.
I don't think that helps, no?
Stop going randomly and fix them in linked groups.
But I don't know how!
Like, I don't even know how to fix this!
I don't know how to fix it!
I'm not just trying to be random.
I am trying to fix it, but I don't know how!
Maybe...
What's still touching?
A whole lot of stuff!
There's a lot of stuff that's touching.
You just fixed it?
No, I didn't.
What, this?
No, it did not fix it at all.
I think it's because what I have set...
Looks nice and pretty to me...
But I need to move things.
You know what I mean?
Okay,
let's see.
This guy... I have no idea.
Ugh!
Gotta undo your work to progress.
I think so too.
Yeah, I think that's what I gotta do.
But my brain doesn't want me to!
Ugh!
My brain is literally like, don't do it!
It looks good.
What kind of sadist created this contraption?
I'll kill them.
I will be the ghost hunting this real kind.
Is there a reset?
I don't know.
Maybe if I leave... No.
Damn.
Okay, let's focus on this area first.
So... What
the hell?
I think this is impossible.
Nancy Drew...
Nancy Drew... Nancy!
I just did what I did before, but made it wider.
Nancy!
Okay.
Let's do this.
Maybe like that.
Like this?
Oh no!
This guy!
Oh gosh!
Ugh!
Okay, hold on.
This guy is... This guy is ruining my mood.
Can I just... Why don't we just break it?
Why don't we just cut it?
Just... It's... The frame is already broken though.
Oh no!
I just realized... Ah!
Okay, ones with a lot of connections go in the middle maybe.
I see people saying that, so we'll try it.
That's... These...
These ones.
Okay.
Let's try it.
Ugh.
The ones with the most connections to the corners?
I think we tried that and it didn't...
Like this seems impossible.
I don't think this works.
Because look at this.
There's too much... There's too much overlap.
There's the most overlap ever.
This is the hardest puzzle ever.
What the hell?
Nancy, Drew, just break it.
Hold on.
Let me... It looks like I need to find a way to make sure none of the wires are crossing.
Ugh!
Nancy!
Nancy, I don't think this... This is possible.
I want the nonograms.
Find pins with three connections or less and make a circle with them.
Are there any like that?
Four?
I don't think there... I don't think there are any with three or less.
There's... There's all... They're all four!
There are none with three or less.
Each line can only touch two unbroken...
broken shapes.
So I think if you try to make shapes... One at a time it should be slow and steady way to do it.
Huh?
Top left has three.
Oh.
Yeah, but that's the only one.
I can't make a shape with a single guy.
I need scissors.
I need an adult!
This is gonna put me... I'm gonna be in the senior citizen home and be like... I'm a... I'm a senior... Detective!
This is gonna be...
Then go four or less and make a circle.
Okay.
There are ones with four.
But not you.
Uh... I made a circle.
Huh?
This music is really... Oh
my god, this one too.
This is really sending me, huh?
What?
What the hell?
I'm looking it up.
Fuck this.
Nancy Drill.
Wire puzzle.
What?
R slash Nancy Drew.
Puzzle Rant.
The picture frame in Saw.
This puzzle.
I almost wasn't able to finish... Oh, Saw.
I guess that's the...
Secret water.
I thought you meant, like, Saw the movie.
You can...
Try moving the longest direct connections closer and gradually move the nodes...
You think you're done with towards the outside.
There may be times you need to flip orders of nodes.
This is an infamous one, huh?
Yeah.
I was fear... I was... I was... I was... Wait, this... I want to read this rant.
I was almost... I almost wasn't able to finish the game because of it.
I have been trying for ages to get past this puzzle.
And after hours and hours of work, it finally paid off.
I was worried at first that I wouldn't like the game.
And therefore wasted so much time and most of it in furious anger at her for making this demonic evil puzzle.
But I'm really glad I... No.
Never mind.
This puzzle never again.
It's terrible.
Easily one of the hardest ones in this series.
Oh my god!
The worst part about it... Someone said the worst part is that if you decide to give up and look at a walkthrough...
It doesn't help!
Because now all the buttons aren't in the same place!
No!
They're right!
Oh, holy...
Okay...
Oh gosh...
I don't know!
Oh my gosh...
Just...
When they said Saw though...
What's this game called?
The...
Shadow at the water's edge or whatever?
I guess they abbreviate it to Saw.
But...
I'm double checking it.
Yeah, shadow at the water's edge.
It's...
This...
This feels like though that it would be an actual puzzle in...
Like the...
The torture movie Saw.
Like it feels like this is not real!
This is not real!
Wait...
That...
Almost works.
Look, this almost works.
Maybe.
You're still here?
Oh yeah!
Bing Bong, you wanna try?
Yeah, you wanna try?
Oh!
Okay, hold on.
Bing Bong over here is a genius.
Says he'll get it immediately for his try.
You can do it easy?
Okay.
I wish I could have...
Twitch Plays...
Mean Toast Dream.
Antidrew.
I seriously just don't...
I don't know.
It is actually just mind-boggling to me right now.
Because as soon as I cross...
One thing, it crosses another!
Vivicor, who are you?
Thank you for the gift.
The one in the middle, move it outside and you have it.
What, this one?
Like that?
There you go.
The problem is solved.
To the top.
Okay.
Good job, team.
I made a cool...
Wait, no.
That doesn't work.
Just cut it, Nancy Drew!
Nancy Drew, just...
Just cut.
Just cut it.
Please, God.
Just destroy the frame.
Just destroy the frame!
We're like making a little...
Something or other here.
But this doesn't work.
I wish I could just see what the shape is that some people are finishing their puzzles with.
You know what I mean?
Can we bring the music back?
Oh, it doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
Oh,
my God.
What?
I'm lost again.
I've been lost from the start.
Nancy Drew, please.
I don't think this is tangible progress.
Oh, quite honestly.
Hold on.
I'm gonna see.
I just looked up what the finished look of the puzzle is.
Let me see.
First picture.
No, it's not first for me.
Uh, definitely not that one from the Reddit.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
I see one!
Okay.
The one with three.
It's here.
Okay.
You know what?
We're just gonna cheese this a little bit.
Okay.
Then this goes...
This...
No, it doesn't.
What?
This goes...
Wait.
This goes here.
Oh, God.
What is this?
No!
Wait.
I thought I had a rough day at work, but it's one puzzle.
I bet the hardy voice would have solved this by now.
You're so right.
Nancy's a stupid woman.
Of course she can't solve this puzzle.
Wait.
This one also has three.
Three.
Okay.
Hold on.
Switch!
No, it doesn't.
I'm a stupid head.
I can't see.
That's four.
Okay.
The one and three.
And then...
One, two, three, four, five.
It's connected to a...
One with...
One, two, three, four...
What?
I think their game is different than mine.
What is happening?
But there was only one piece that had three.
Three connections.
No?
Right?
There was only the one piece.
It was this one.
Right?
Are you able to reset the puzzle?
Nope.
You are not allowed to because the game aids now.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
I'm just recreating what they did.
In this...
In this photo.
Okay?
I'm recreating how they did it in this photo.
Okay.
What?
Huh?
You're not allowed to parce you six minutes?
Every copy of Nancy Drew Saw is personalized.
Oh, the music is back.
Wait, but this isn't like the picture.
Oh, I thought this was connected to this one.
I feel... wait.
Ah, one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
And then this is one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
One, two... one, two, three, four, five, six...
There has to be another one with three connections.
But I don't see any.
Four...
This is the only one with three!
Then why?
In the picture...
Okay, I'm gonna... hold on, let me get the picture up for you guys.
I don't know.
Wait!
Oh, wait.
What if the picture I'm looking at...
Is from the baby...
Detective.
And I'm on the senior detective.
I'm no good at these, but my nephew...
See, he loves them.
I'm gonna get some chili.
Oh, one more thing!
Senior...
Oh my gosh, I can't find... I can't find anywhere that...
Wait!
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Just a minute!
Okay, I might've... I might've...
I might've...
I might've found a solution!
Okay, let's try this one.
No one played senior.
They all knew better!
They were like...
They all knew about this puzzle!
They all knew about this puzzle and was like hell no I'm not doing that.
They saved themselves!
Okay, hold on.
Like that, maybe.
And... No, no, no.
So, anybody, don't use this as a walkthrough.
Oh my god!
I can't believe this is so stupid.
Okay, okay.
What?
The seniors are too old to post a guide.
Speed run.
Hold on, hold on.
Oh wait, is this... Hold on.
Origami?
There's origami too?
Maybe we can come back to this.
Holy... Oh yeah.
How long?
The wires?
Takes this person only ten minutes.
You mother trucker.
How do you do it in ten minutes?
Okay, hold on.
There are other puzzles we can do in the meantime.
You know what?
Let's just do that.
Let's take a break, everybody.
Let's take a break.
We gotta go find grandma.
She's somewhere around here.
Where?
I just don't know where.
Oh, maybe in here.
Oh, no.
That's a hallway.
Oh my god.
Game, please.
I'm scared.
Wait.
Oh.
Turn around.
Grandma!
I understand why that guy was going crazy.
So this is a hallway.
And this is rooms.
Are they all rooms?
I need a key to open this door.
Locked.
Okay.
These are all bedrooms.
I feel like I've gone down...
This is a hallway.
Yes.
Maybe this is a hallway.
I think if that guy is a literal...
Robotics engineer, he should be able to solve it.
I'm just saying.
It should not be on Nancy Drew.
A.K.A.
me.
Where is grandma?
I'm watching this walkthrough.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
That gave me a literal stomach ache, you guys.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I'm sorry.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Sorry about that.
I wanted to go get some more water.
So grandma should be...
Right here!
Hello?
Locked.
Is it too late?
Grandma?
I need a key to open this door.
But my cultural...
Experience!
Locked.
Welcome back.
Okaeri.
Tadai Ma!
Can use the clock on the phone.
Oh, it's almost at midnight.
Wow.
We spent so much time traveling to Pachinko.
Um...
What time did it say it was open?
7 a.m.
Alright, let's set an alarm for 7 a.m., baby.
Looking up untangling plan or graphs.
There's some web versions called Planarity that are free to play.
I don't want to go through all of that, though.
I don't want to go through all of that.
Okay, clock.
7 a.m.
I think I'll sleep somewhere more reasonable.
What do you mean, sleep?
Nancy Drew.
This is...
You're pulling an all-nighter, girlfriend.
Here we go.
Back to the...
Back to hell.
Grandma said finish your puzzle.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Finish your puzzle.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going back to my tutorial.
Uh...
The person, even in the tutorial, is like...
Kinda, like...
They don't know.
I'm scat...
Ah!
Is that it?
That's it!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay!
Think they look fun.
Good luck, everybody else.
You can all have fun with your little puzzle.
I...
I have no interest.
I will never touch this again.
I...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
I never want to see this.
I never...
Ha ha ha ha.
I never want to see it again.
Okay.
Well, this is gonna be a doozy.
So we'll start with our three-pronged one.
Which they have...
Uh...
Right here.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Wait.
Let me make sure.
Okay.
That one goes down here.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This is our three-three prog.
This is our three connection.
So then...
Then...
This one goes here.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Three...
Four, five, six, seven.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Okay.
Just follow along, everybody, for now.
Follow along for now.
And then, Neil, go here.
Okay, follow along for now.
Are you guys following?
Are you guys following along for now?
Okay.
Are you guys following?
I don't... This... It's not easy for me, okay?
If it's easy for you, that's so wonderful for you.
It's not easy for me.
So...
And I don't think it's a very easy thing to describe in text, so, um... Okay, um... One, two, three.
Maybe, like, here.
Right?
Okay, the one that connects, so this... No, because this needs... Uh, shoot.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Where's our other seven... seven connection?
This one?
Maybe, no.
Uh, oh.
One, two, three, four, five, no.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven!
I'm throwing you over here.
Oh, see, see, see, see?
See, see, see, see, see?
Remember, any wists that want to make a fangame for Minto, please don't.
Please don't!
Do you hate me?
Oh, Minto, she's so cute when she's dumb.
She's so cute when she doesn't know how to get out.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, two...
Three, four, five.
Okay, so I think this one goes here.
Mm-hmm.
And we're gonna have a one, two, three, four...
Up here.
It could be...
It could be any of these, though.
I don't know.
Please make Minto P-Cross instead of whatever this thing...
Yeah!
Make a P-Cross, make a nonogram.
I will do that so much.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I accidentally took it out of full screen.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-mm.
I feel like...
What I had is almost close to what they have.
So maybe I really was a genius after all.
Maybe I was a genius after all.
Wait a second.
What the hell?
I don't know.
I'm just kind of moving some things around.
It seems a little random right now.
Because it is.
One, two, three, four.
One, two...
Wait.
The whole right side looks great.
Yeah!
Yeah, it does.
But I'm lost now.
Let's start from our roots.
Like this.
This I know is for sure.
And then this one I think goes like here-ish.
Oh.
This will move out.
So this...
Is here.
Wait a second.
Oh, there's one...
Maybe this goes here.
Ah!
I think so.
And then...
This one has this maybe go here.
Oh!
This one is supposed to have...
One, two, three, four.
Maybe this goes here.
I got the backing off the portrait.
Nice job.
That's it?
Certificate of spirit removal.
What's this?
I'm sorry.
Konnichiwa.
Certificate of spirit removal.
This is the...
Puzzle Master Rita.
Woo-hoo, Rita!
Thank you!
First try.
Yeah!
Wow!
Thank you so much.
Teal.
Thank you, thank you for the...
Thank you.
First try.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you for the...
Thank you, thank you.
This is to certify that Relkan Hiei has been cleansed of all malevolent, disruptive, or mischievous spirits, and upon this day is considered fit for human habitation.
Special attention has been paid to all spaces under beds and within closets.
These areas have been certified 100% permanently ghost-free, even during the middle of the night.
Victory!
Yeah!
It has been duly noted and added to the public record that all spirits previously dwelling in said domicile are now considered non-resident and shall behave themselves accordingly.
At no point will the aforementioned spirits, ghosts, or lurking specters be allowed to return to their previous places of residence.
Without the express written provision of all human residents in the residence.
A-okay!
Signed, Savannah Woodham-sama, paranormal expert.
Oh, yes.
This is our very...
Japanese exorcism by Savannah-sama.
You guys wouldn't get anything like this.
I mean, it wouldn't work.
But, like, you guys wouldn't do this, right?
That's so silly.
Oh.
I should hold on to this article.
Oh, god.
Oh.
I'm, like, tr- Very, very vaguely piecing together- I can't read kanji.
Oh, it's saying, like, it seems like, uh, the daughter...
Uh, found the mom.
Ooh.
That's not good.
Kanji hard.
Wait, how do I...
Um, oh, I took it.
Okay.
That's it?
Hi.
Um, do you know anything about the certificate behind the portrait?
Do you know anything about the certificate behind the portrait?
Who's Savannah Woodham?
She was an investigator.
She helped out with the investigation after Kasumi died.
An investigator?
This certificate seems a little less than official.
Don't forget to save.
Oh, thank you, Ava.
She was more of a paranormal investigator.
I don't really believe in that stuff personally, but Takai wanted her here.
Takai.
Why did Takai want a paranormal investigator?
I've known Takai since I was a kid.
Takai.
And let me tell you this from experience.
It is impossible to guess what she's thinking or why she doesn't...
What she does.
What do you mean?
Oh.
I'm sure you'll find out.
Let me save.
So true.
Shadow.
Minto shadow.
Shit.
Can you translate this for me?
Sure.
No.
Put this back where you got it.
Uh.
I don't think you like that.
Hey.
Oh.
Do you know what scare- Oh wait.
Do you know where I can get a card for the pachinko parlor?
It seems like I'm always running into those things.
Guests leave them everywhere.
Oh.
Take a look around.
I'm sure you'll find one.
What?
That's not helpful at all.
It's just like...
Why are all...
I don't...
Is pachinko that common for like tourists to do?
I've never done it before.
Like...
Is it...
Yeah.
Pick up the trash that the...
That the previous residences...
Uh...
Residents...
Guests...
Uh...
Just left here.
I don't know.
Just find one.
Lamal.
Do you know what's scaring the guests away?
Series stu-per-stitions.
Stu-per-stitions.
We have ghost hunters who come here to find ghosts.
And if they think they've found something, they get all panicked and run away.
This guy is so sussy.
I'll let you get back to work.
See you later.
He...
I feel like he...
Say there's like...
He can build stuff, right?
So I feel like he would be able to build something to make like a cl...
You know, crashing noises or whatever.
I think this guy is sus.
Because...
I'm gonna ask her to translate it because Nancy has no decorum.
And it's almost when I am...
Hi.
Oh gosh.
It's about...
Is it about her mom?
It's so horrible.
I found an old article.
Can you tell me what it says?
Sure.
Where did you get this?
You have no right to have this.
The good news, at least it was Miwako who caught you and not some creepy ghost.
Bad news, what you did mean Miwako's still in her room right now?
That can't be!
Wait, what are you talking about?
Oh, oh!
I...
They killed me!
What are
you...
Um...
I hear this place has a reputation as a destination for ghost hunters.
We didn't ask for it.
It's all that stupid book.
Those people, they have no respect for anyone or anything.
Ooh...
I can't believe we can get a game over this.
Can you tell me about that?
What?
That's no offense, but that seems sort of silly.
A certificate?
So you don't know anything about it?
No.
And where exactly did you find this certificate?
Behind the portrait I helped Rentaro repair.
Maybe you should stay away from what isn't yours.
And maybe he should have the sense to know what is a family matter.
I have to get back to work now.
Okay!
Damn!
Nancy Drew!
Your decorum please!
I think it's this side.
Is...
Our...
Our room, right?
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Number 24!
This one?
26.
Damn it.
24.
26.
Uh, 24!
Oh!
Our bed has been set up!
Wow!
Any ghosts?
How am I supposed to find just a pachinko card?
All the rooms are locked.
Okay.
Uh...
Wait, how do I get to bed?
Turn around.
There we go.
Alright.
Wait, uh, turn around.
We did this.
We did all of this.
Go to sleep...
Oh, wait.
Uh, let me...
If I set my alarm now, I think.
It'll work.
Clock.
7...
AM.
Okay.
I'll be busy then.
I should set the alarm for a later time.
What do you mean busy?
What are you doing?
I'll be busy then.
What are you...
I'll be teaching then.
I should set the alarm for...
I'll be teaching...
I'll be teaching then.
I'll be busy then.
Can't set my alarm for then.
Oh my god.
I'll be teaching then.
It's really late.
I should get to bed.
I'll be teaching, I'll be, I'll be teaching, I'll be, oh my god.
Oh, alarm!
Let's go make some origami, baby!
Okay.
Oh, whoops, wrong way.
Okay, origami, origami.
Origami, origami.
My cultural room.
Nanasi-san, please, sit.
What did you call me?
Nanasi-san?
Nanasi?
I am sorry for the way I behaved when you Farast arrived.
Farast?
It was very impolite.
Please, forgive me.
Of course, don't worry.
It's nice to meet you as well.
That is very kind of you to say.
But I must always worry about the guests who stay with us.
I think she's French.
From France.
What is this?
What do you mean, especially now?
Are you here for a lesson today?
What is this accent?
The guests.
A lesson?
I offer lesson in traditional arts to anyone interested in learning.
I have much to show you.
Oh, okay.
Actually, I'd rather ask you a few questions.
Oh, no, we'll do that.
Sounds great.
Why are you shaking your head?
Today, you will be learning katakana.
Oh, no.
To the outsider, katakana always looks far more difficult to learn than it is.
Wait, we're learning katakana for real?
You just need to be patient, and you need to learn to see more than you are used to seeing.
There is a book to help in the chest.
In the chest.
Practice.
Until it looks like your name, Nanatsi.
Nanatsi.
Not just some lines.
What do you mean?
Although there are many Nanatsis in the world.
Nanatsis?
What?
It's getting worse.
Your name belongs to only you.
It has always been yours.
You must try until what you see on the paper is not just a word.
It is you.
Wait.
I pick up my pen.
That's not quite right.
What are you talking about?
What?
How do I get rid of it?
She already wrote my name.
Wait.
No, no.
Grandma.
Grandma, please.
How do I get it?
Sit back down, Nanatsi.
Hello, Nanatsi-san.
Ah!
She got my name right!
I'd like to try calligraphy.
I'd like to try calligraphy again.
I don't understand.
So, like, big blotch.
Okay.
Big blotch.
Why was I wrong before?
Ugh.
Not quite.
Time to try again.
No, Nanatsi!
Who
needs duolingo when you have Nanatsi, Drew?
Okay, okay.
In the lines.
What?
If you just keep practicing, I'll get it.
Nanatsi.
They're so strict.
No.
You think too much.
Just practice.
I'm trying!
You're laughing too hard.
This is scary.
What if I do this one first?
Almost.
Okay.
So, you have to...
Slow.
Okay.
Indiana Jones, Nanatsi.
All right.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
All right.
This is where we fumbled last time.
Oh!
Okay!
Nanatsi!
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay.
That worked.
Duh!
Please.
Please, God.
Please!
The music is not helping.
Yeah!
Very well done, Nancy.
This is the best I've ever seen from a new student.
I knew you could do this well.
Leave this to dry, and I'll have it brought to your room to remind you of your success.
Success?
Thank you!
Oh, no.
I think she'll kill me if I ask her...
Hold on.
Save.
Can you translate this article for me?
I'd be happy to, Nancy-san.
I don't think you will be.
Why would you give me this?
Put it back where it goes.
Now!
Okay, my bad.
It's fine.
I love the gardens.
Do you take care of them?
Yes, of course.
I sleep here, but my home is out there, in the gardens.
Where?
Even when the whole earth is covered in snow.
What?
I am happiest there.
She doesn't actually mean that she...
Waiting for the first flowers to break through the fast.
Do yourself a favor, Nancy-san.
Nancy-san.
Find a small piece of earth that begs to be made perfect.
And do whatever it asks of you.
You will thank me.
What?
Find a small piece of earth that begs to be made perfect.
And do whatever it asks of you.
What?
The ryokan seems very important to you.
The world around has become a million different things since I was a girl.
Gar.
And I do not have to tell you...
Since I was a gar.
That many changes have not been so good.
But in here, the world does not change.
The world does not change.
Why do you want Yumi to take over the ryokan?
It is tradition.
Any other reason?
I am used to this question.
Tradition is very often made fun of or ignored.
Is that why we don't?
The tradition is how we know ourselves, Nancy-san.
The traditions of your family are how you know yourself.
Tradition is a burden in many ways.
Grandma's yapping.
I understand this.
She talks so slowly.
But imagine not knowing who you are or where you come from.
It would be very lonely, I think.
She's dodging the question.
What if it's the girl at the reception and her boyfriend conspiring together because she wants to own the ryokan?
I looked up the cast list.
Only Miwako's voice actress is Japanese.
I see.
We fixed the portrait.
I think it's back up in the lobby.
It is.
Yes.
Rantaro tells me that it's very important to you.
It is very important to all of us.
Why were you so upset when it fell?
Because it's important to them.
You would be upset if something new broke.
Yeah.
There was more to it than that.
No.
That was all.
They want to make it into a different type of ryokan.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe she wants to take it over.
And like, the sister wants to make it, keep it traditional.
And the other girl is just like, duh.
I want to make it new.
Because she's discovered her mom or whatever.
So she's like, I don't know.
Have you always lived at the ryokan?
Ryokan.
Since I was born.
Have you ever left?
I have.
Damn.
But I never found anywhere I wanted to be as much as here.
Robot cat maids!
Let her take it.
Have you always offered classes?
No.
It is new.
We have developed a reputation.
And for many years, I've wanted to teach our guests.
I think you need to be less strict.
I come here.
I come...
Why are her eyes...
Did you see her eyes just dart just then?
She was just like...
Oh, they're just there.
Grandma.
Don't smile at me.
You're so strict, Grandma.
I just tried to write my name and you had me do it 50 times.
I'll let you go.
Goodbye.
Shifty.
Nancy.
Okay.
What time is it?
7.10.
Wow.
That took us 10 minutes, guys.
What's this?
I'm being nosy.
Nosy Nancy.
Oh!
Writing Japanese.
Learn the difference between hiragana and katakana.
Oh, boy.
Wait.
This is an actual...
Oh, wow!
And katakana too.
Wow!
Writing the Japanese languages...
Languages?
Does it count as a different language?
Involves the use of two separate syllabaries.
Hiragana and katakana.
Consisting of 46 symbols in both syllabaries.
Sil...
La...
Each character represents a complete syllable instead of a single letter.
The hiragana syllabary...
Sorry.
Is mainly used for word endings while katakana is mainly used to write foreign loan words and names.
Oh, oh, oh.
In addition to hiragana and katakana, a third group of characters known as kanji are also used.
In kanji, each character represents a different meaning and there are thousands of these characters.
It is a lengthy undertaking and elementary students are given until the end of sixth grade to learn the 1006 basic characters.
The following charts contain the characters for both the hiragana and katakana syllabaries.
Japanese is typically written vertically, from right to left, but can also be written horizontally, left to right.
Okay.
Everybody learn right now.
Here's the most important ones.
Mi...
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mi...
Minto.
Or katakana.
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi Is that the thing that I want?
Mito!
Wait, put it back.
Oh, sorry.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
What should I write?
Oh my gosh, I'm going to be like one of those streamers that's like, Give me your name and I'll write it in Japanese.
Oh, yeah.
Give me your name and I'll write it in Japanese.
Yes.
Don't make fun of my stroke order though.
Oppai!
Oh, good one.
Oppai.
Suki.
Oppai suki.
Sorry, it's a little lumpy.
That's my face when I see oppai.
What else should I write?
Oh, here's a good one.
Ta-y...
Ga...
Fa-y...
I-y...
Ta-y-gah-fai-ya...
Ta-y-ga-fai-ya-sai-i-ma-fai-ma-daimama-ma-ma-ma.
Imagine some American girl walks into your ryokan and starts writing Oppai suki.
In Perfect Kata-kana.
What else?
Five wiper!
Oh!
Me...
Taaru...
Geah.
Suki?
What kind of question?
As long as it says, I'm so sorry for this.
I want to say...
Oh...
Snake...
...
Did you know Kai's is part Japanese?
What?
That guy is part Japanese?
Wow.
Here, I'll draw.
I feel so like... With the music.
Creature.
That's its other foot.
Don't get it twisted.
That's a lot of strokes for one freaky character.
You're shuffling on the ground.
Like a...
Like a little bug.
Just like that.
That's the sound.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's some impeccable brushwork boss.
Thank you.
What can I write?
Click the guy from Fate.
La Freak.
Alright.
Let's save.
What time is it now, Nancy?
Holy!
We've been drawing for 30 minutes!
Wait to write yaoi right now.
Why?
Oh, got nothing in here.
Gosh, I'm so nosy!
These are not my closets.
Um, where are we going to?
Uh, maybe here?
Hello!
Can you tell me anything about Takai?
Takai?
She can be a little tough.
But she's really wonderful.
She works herself way too hard, though.
I wish I could get her to just relax a little.
But you can't tell her to do anything unless you want a lecture back in return.
I take it you've been lectured by Takai before.
I pretty much grew up here.
And believe it or not, I was not always the saint you see standing before you.
Wait, so he's a childhood friend?
So...
What do you mean you weren't the saint?
I've been on the sad end of a lecture or two.
But I've overheard more.
Always hilarious when they're not directed at you.
What do you mean- What troubles have you been into, Rentaro?
I'll talk to you later.
Peace out.
What do you mean the saint that you see here?
What?
What is he talking about?
What does he mean by that?
Let's go talk to her, I suppose.
Sush.
I wonder if we can wait until like- Hello?
Until like 1am or whatever?
And then she won't be here and we can talk- We can see behind here, you know?
Do you think that the Ria Khan is haunted?
By what?
Ghosts?
No.
Ghosts aren't real, Nancy.
Your next is Miwako's computer when she's not there.
Ah, si, si, si!
I'll let you go.
I guessed it, I guessed it.
Hehehe.
Um, maybe then, what should we do?
Oh.
I wonder if we can try and find a card, I guess.
Wait.
I wonder.
If the bathrooms aren't right.
Oh, they're for women!
We can go!
We can go to the- We can go to the- We can go to the- Let's see.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
Oh.
Oh, Nancy?
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's so scary!
What?!
Oh!
What the... What the hell was that?
Scary!
Ouch, ouch!
What?
I have Lentalo take care of it right away.
Until then, please stay away.
I don't want you to get hurt.
But I saw something.
I'm sure of it.
You work too hard, Nancy-san.
Up too late, off to teach so early.
You must rest more.
Your judgment suffers if you do not get enough rest.
Reflectionless vampire, right?
I know what I saw.
Nancy-san, please.
I have to ask you to let me get back to work.
Um... What?
This music is crazy.
What is happening?
Wait, let me go back.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
Let me go back!
I think I have to go up and then turn around.
Maybe?
There we go.
Okay.
I want to go back to the hot springs.
That was so freaky, you guys!
That was so stinking scary!
What the hell?
Oh!
This looks important.
I should figure out where I can use it.
Yeah!
We got the pachinko card!
Let's go!
Oh...
Oh, it's the only...
Oh no?
And a trophy?
Ghost looks at a mirror, sees a ghost, gets scared.
What about this one?
Haunted Tors!
Went on the search for ghosts.
You want to make sure you don't call in any additional bad luck.
Here are 13 Japanese superstitions to be aware of.
But you guys want ghosts, right?
Or ghosts.
You guys don't want to get rid of ghosts.
You guys want more ghosts.
The number four is pronounced chi.
The same as the word for death.
And it is considered very unlucky.
As a result, many hotels do not have a number four or a fourth floor.
A room number four or a fourth floor.
The number nine and the word pain also share the pronunciation ku.
Though not as unlucky as four, nine is still frequently skipped in numbering rooms on floors...
Or floors in hospitals.
Whistling at night will attract s- s- s- sne- snake?
Why can't I whistle right now?
Did it work?
He's here!
Oh my gosh!
Snake, you came to see me!
One haunting, please.
Avoid sticking chopsticks upright in a bowl of rice as this is traditionally part of the funeral ritual.
Yeah, looks like the incense.
Don't sleep with your head pointing north.
Oh.
Breaking a comb or the strap of your geta sandal will bring bad luck.
Never write another person's name in red ink.
Something bad will happen to them if you do.
Oh wait, what about this?
It's supposed... Oh, there we go.
Big me to love.
Yeah, thank you!
Seeing a spider in the morning is good luck!
I saw a spider today.
But seeing one at night is bad.
You better not show yourself, little guy.
He was actually pretty big.
Director's note.
She kissed her little man right now.
Yeah, I did.
Badgers?
Not cats.
Thank you for...
clarifying.
Are considered unlucky because they wear masks to hide their eyes.
What does that have to do with ghosts?
Why did it single out cats?
I don't know!
If you lie down immediately after eating, you'll turn into a cow?
Hide your thumb in if a funeral car passes you.
Okay.
Blood type influences one personality.
That's not a superstition.
Well, I guess it is, kind of, but...
Ugh!
Never pass food from chopstick to chopstick.
This is another funeral ritual.
An eye...
Snake was here!
He left his eye patch!
And his beauty blender!
And his comb!
And his mug!
And...
His back massager!
I can't believe it!
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh god, that scared me.
Uh...
Turn around?
Whoa!
It looks like something is missing here.
It does?
I don't see it.
Wait, that's...
Nancy, you didn't shower!
She's dirty!
Nancy Drew, you dirty, dirty!
You're supposed to shower before you get in!
The whistling worked!
Yeah, it did!
Nancy-san...
Nancy-san, where is your respect for the culture?
Kite and behavior!
Truly!
Nasty Nancy!
She's ruining the bath for everybody else.
Well, that was spooky!
Um...
Uh, let's go talk to...
What's his name?
And see if he has anything to say about the ghost lady we saw in...
Hey!
Um...
Do you know what happened to the mirror in the baths?
Oh, that thing.
I sort of hid it a few years back and put a little heroin crack in it.
Its days have been numbered for a while.
Sorry about breaking it.
What?
Oh, no!
Don't worry.
I'm just glad you didn't get hurt.
Mirrors can be very dangerous when they're breaking.
In more ways than one.
What do you mean?
Oh, shards of glass and such.
Not something to fool around with.
Something weird happened when I looked in the mirror.
I didn't see my...
Wait, that's cat...
That's actually...
That wasn't just a game thing?
Wait, we actually weren't supposed to see our reflection?
Something weird happened.
When I looked in the mirror, I didn't see my reflection.
Aha!
You know what happened?
You're a vampire!
That's a vampire!
Seriously, though, that's pretty messed up.
Maybe you need to get a little rest.
This place might be getting to you a little.
No, I need more nonograms.
I'm back for more nonograms.
Here you go!
Thank you.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Catch you around!
He's been eating whatever the hell that is.
Oh, wait.
Maybe he's not eating.
I thought he was eating a little thing.
He's looking at something.
I thought he was...
I was like, he's been eating that for a long time.
It's 9 p.m.
Uh...
Wait, I can take a picture of him.
Wow, 2010 camera.
This looks really creepy, huh?
Real...
Real creeper shot here.
Oh, God.
I saved it.
Can you set it as your wallpaper?
Oh, let's try it.
Settings.
Background.
Dave Gregory?
Who the hell is this?
I'm Dave Gregory.
The Canute Farmhouse?
Okay, cute.
Lounge.
Okay.
Snorkeling.
Cute.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, a turtle!
That's fun.
Kyler Mallory.
Why?
Who are these?
Uh...
It's locked.
Oh, that's cute!
It's like the original Nancy Drew pictures!
Wait, that's so cute.
Classic.
Aw.
Silhouette.
Ooh.
Okay, Dave Gregory.
Green, obviously.
Oh, shut up!
Oh, my God!
Oh, shut up.
Oh,
my God.
You know what that just reminded me of?
Did anybody else have the Nickelodeon alarm clock?
That did that?
I'm gonna be like, Wake up!
Wake up!
You still have one!
That's crazy!
Boop, boop, boop, boop!
I think this is Arthur Morgan.
Oh, God!
Let's do the explosion.
I like that.
Do I have any messages?
Nobody loves me!
How do I change the photo?
God, the beeping sound is so annoying, though.
Okay, I guess we'll go to sleep.
I guess?
Is there, like, a time limit in this game?
I don't know.
Okay.
Yeah, we're on the right side.
Oh!
Wait!
No, no, no!
We can go to Pachinko!
I forgot.
Yeah, Pachinko time, baby!
All right, so it was, uh...
All the way at Kurei.
Oh, wait!
Oh!
No way!
We have a speed!
Yeah!
Nice.
Nancy Drew's crippling Pachinko addiction.
Look, it didn't even take any time!
I need to find a card first before I can play Pachinko.
I did.
This one.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Wait, it's actual.
Come on!
Come on, flower!
Oh!
Yippee!
Okay.
I have 47 balls left.
Flower!
Nice.
I keep getting the little beaver.
I don't...
How many do I need?
Please!
Please, flower!
Oh!
Ugh.
How many did I need?
You need to play a lot to get all the prizes.
Oh!
So close!
So rude.
Oh!
Oh yeah!
Okay, nice!
Okay, it's not worth it.
Nice!
So close.
To flower...
Frog!
40 winnings!
Let's go!
Okay, nice.
Okay, flower is totally worth it.
Flower is the way.
Big winnings!
Come on, flower!
Please!
Ah!
Yeah!
I love gambling!
Nice!
We got the...
The...
Little raccoon.
Ah!
What's that mean?
Oh, maybe because I didn't get a star.
But I should have a star.
I think that's a hole.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh yeah, at least got something.
Oh, oh, so close!
Please!
Uh-oh.
Yeah!
Can Pachinko be the rest of the game?
Oh my god!
We almost...
I hit the jackpot, I think.
Okay.
200!
We have 20 left, you guys.
Come on.
Nanshi-doru!
Nanshi!
9-9-9th Nancy Drew Game.
Nancy Drew The Vanishing Wallet and Gambling Curse.
Yeah, Nancy hasn't been the same since she came back from Japan.
Oh, come on.
Nice!
Ready for three hour pachinko.
I don't know how many I need, though, for it.
We only have 10 balls left.
Oh, come on.
That was the worst one.
Oh, nice!
Oh, come on!
Sometimes the other ones will, like, hit it.
Come on!
Nanshi!
Yippee!
That's all of our earnings.
Nice.
I'd like to see what the comic has to say about hauntings.
I don't have enough for anything.
No way.
Way.
I don't have...
I have nothing.
I'm taking my earnings with me.
I'm sorry, but what are these even?
That this costs 790 balls.
This is really...
This is balls, this game.
All right, Nancy.
Time to go home.
It's been 10 minutes since we've played.
We got here so fast.
Back to our creepy hotel.
Gosh.
How can I get more?
Please.
Hi.
I'm addicted.
I'll let you go.
I'm addicted to gambling.
Please.
Wait, we need to wait until 1 a.m.
No?
What should we do?
Dave is so dreamy.
What should we...
I know what we can do.
Nonogram.
Time to join the Yakuza to get money for Pachinko.
Nancy must gamble.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh.
Oops.
It is?
Oh my gosh.
What?
There we go.
The music is all creepy again.
Just give me...
Let me play one game.
Wait.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
Okay.
Good.
Um...
Let me just do one game.
One game.
I promise.
Just one.
This is me...
This is literally what I look like before I go to sleep.
I'm just playing P-Cross.
Or...
You know...
Not P-Cross.
Meow Tower.
Um...
Oh.
Wait.
Wait?
I think 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
12.
You.
Wait.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 9, 10, 11.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I can't count.
I was gonna say that's not right at all.
5.
3, 4.
2, 2, 3.
There we go.
Yep.
4.
5.
Ta-da.
We require an entire nonogram stream now.
Too much pressure.
I like to just play.
Otherwise, I mess up.
5, 6, 7.
Too much pressure.
2, 2, 2, 3, 1.
Okay.
2, 3, 4.
I mean, keep watching from work.
Have a nice evening.
You too.
2, okay.
Uh, 4.
Um, 5.
Oh, 2, 1.
1.
Uh.
What am I missing?
This one's done too.
Five.
Like that.
Four.
See, it's actually quite easy.
You know.
It's actually quite easy.
Even I get mixed up sometimes too.
As you saw earlier.
But it's actually very simple.
Tanuki.
Oh, I see it.
I do.
I see it.
So cute.
I like that one.
Two.
Let's see.
One, one.
What else am I missing?
One, one, real.
This one, yeah.
But I don't know which one it is.
Gotta be around the cheeks, right?
Probably like that.
Let's see if it works.
Solved it.
Um.
This is actually a badger whom we cannot trust.
Because he wears a mask over his eyes.
What?
It's only 10.02!
10.03.
Uh.
Back to Pachinko.
Someone said it's unlimited, right?
Wait.
Let's go back to Pachinko, I suppose.
Away from this haunted-ass...
Location.
Scary.
Could be a cat.
I don't think it's a cat.
Do-do-do-do.
Are we sure it's unlimited?
I'll try.
It is unlimited!
Oh.
Wait.
Why did I see like five of them drop down just now?
I don't.
Winnings!
Ugh.
Come
on!
Come on!
Do-do-do-do-do.
We got more than last time though.
Damn.
Come on!
Big winnings!
Star.
Wow.
This sucks.
Take my winnings and I'll go elsewhere.
To you!
Wait, they actually look different.
That's kind of crazy.
Go, go, go!
It's so loud when it does that.
Let's go gambling!
Making big money.
How much do I have?
600!
The reason why it's free is because the card is using someone else's wallet.
Damn, how much we got now?
1024, how much was it?
Wait.
Guys, it's different stuff.
This must be the comic.
But it's different stuff.
This one's so expensive.
Grandma would love this because she's saying that I'm experiencing real Japanese culture.
Oops.
So don't worry about it.
She would be like, wow, this is authentic...
Oops, sorry.
Japanese culture.
People line up at like 6 in the morning to do this.
And it's not gambling, it's just little balls.
Proud grandma moment.
Uh-oh.
Guys, our big earnings.
Where's our big earnings?
We're gonna walk out with 5?
Okay, come on.
Huh?
That should've been huge jackpot.
Huge jackpot!
What the?
Spooky number!
The adventures of Koji and Kit.
Yure.
Shiawase Comics.
What else do you guys want?
It's on...
Wait, I could get you...
What are these?
I'll get it.
Oh, it's a little bell.
That costs too much.
It's a little bell.
That one's for you, little princess.
Pachinko Queen!
What time is it?
It's only 10.19!
Let's try for the whale.
We're whaling!
Get it?
Get it!
This is our lucky one.
This is my first stone, no sag.
Oh, sorry!
Some...
I said earlier at the beginning of the stream that I'm not gonna...
Be able to see all of them.
I'm sorry.
Is this game in real time?
No, it can't be.
Wait.
No!
It's 10.21 for me right now.
Wait, you guys.
It's literally like the time on Nancy's phone for me right now.
She found her true calling.
Thank you to whoever told me about the card being...
Unlimited because...
That was huge.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Are you Nancy Drew?
Oh my god!
It's literally 10.22 for me right now!
Okay, just turn to 10.23 in the game, but...
That's freaky!
No!
It's a little freaky, no?
We hit something big.
This is the luckiest machine ever, you guys.
They forgot to rig this one.
Oh, that almost was a jackpot.
Oh, yeah!
It's also 10.23 for me now.
East Coast, best coast.
East Coast.
All right!
How much we got?
1,500.
I'm unstoppable.
I'm robbing them blind.
Oh!
I think I'm too good at this game.
Jackpot again.
Yeah!
How much was it?
26.
Okay.
Maybe a game or two more.
Oops.
A game or two more!
But we have to wait until 1am.
I could try setting an alarm, but it says, like, I should sleep.
I don't think she knows about the computer yet.
Maybe she does.
I don't know.
For now, I'll just get the...
I'll just get the whale.
I'm getting a cough drop real quick.
My throat's hurting a little bit today.
Oh!
I broke the game.
Wait, I broke it!
Oh, there they go.
There they go.
Gambling looks really easy.
I gotta try this.
I know!
Maybe you can change PC clock.
I don't think it's real time.
But that would be crazy though.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
I keep forgetting these fights.
1am.
Don't say you're busy.
This would be a strange place to sleep.
Why are we sleeping here?
One whale for you, my princess.
Wait, it's not in my inventory.
Oh, yes it is.
Um...
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where did he go?
Is he on my phone?
He's on my phone!
That's so cute!
Wait, that's actually so cute.
Back when phone charms were popular.
Oh!
Sorry guys.
I'm so sorry.
I can't stop it.
I'm addicted to the...
I'm addicted to the balls.
I'm addicted to the bing bong bing when I get jackpot!
Kinda looks like a wisp.
I can see it.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
Let's go to my room.
And we'll sleep...
Ugh, I keep doing this.
Locked.
I know.
We'll sleep until 1am.
Uh...
1am.
Hello?
So they put my Nancy Drew on the...
That's exactly how I wrote it.
Was that an explosion?
What the hell?
What the hell was that?
To
the explosion.
To the explosion.
Suki.
Suki, tate.
Oh god, it's horrifying.
Oh, it's even worse.
Experience the Bavarian Alps.
Greece.
Dread Isles.
Shark diving.
Fun.
We are being so nosy.
Oh my god.
What's up, cat?
Suki, tate.
Tate.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Suki, who's a good girl?
Girl.
I'd better get back to the case.
Okay.
Um, let me say it real quick.
Looks like I'll need a password.
What would the password be?
Wait.
Uh...
What would the password be?
Suki?
But it's so long.
Oh.
Suki, tate?
Minto, tate.
Suki, tate.
That's all she knows in Japanese.
Oh, where's ta?
Ta?
Oh, ta, tate.
Tate.
What about what we wrote in earlier?
Nancy Drew?
What a horrifying wallpaper, even.
Oh, what could it be?
Stop!
Oh, I thought I'd...
I thought I'd get him while he was asleep.
Uh...
Maybe in Rentaro?
Hmm...
There's probably a clue somewhere on the desk.
Check behind me.
Oh!
Wait...
I don't think I can check behind me.
Oh, wait!
Yes, I can!
What is this?
Oh, it's one of these types of puzzles!
Wait, if I move it around, is it...
Oh!
Wait...
Okay, hold on.
So, if I move like this...
Okay, what about...
Okay...
Oh, this one's not any different, huh?
Oh...
That one only...
Wait...
Am I stupid?
Why...
Is it not moving?
I think we're...
Maybe we're missing one, no?
Yeah, we're missing red.
Okay, hold on.
Okay...
KrollmeisterCard3000.
Having difficulty remembering all those number security codes?
Worry no more!
Introducing the KrollmeisterCard3000.
The latest in state-of-the-art keycard security systems.
Our system uses an 8x8 grid with a unique colored entry code designed by the user.
The colors are then split and encoded onto 5 keycards by our team of specialists.
With extra squares on each card for added security.
To open the secured compartment, place the keycards in the slots in the correct layering order and rotate their displays until they match the entry code pattern.
Okay...
So yeah, we are missing one.
But I can rotate it?
Or...
Oh!
I see!
Okay...
Oh, so it's like a double.
You have to first get it in the order and then also rotate it in the correct way.
Okay, interesting.
But that doesn't help us with the TV...
With the computer.
Oh god!
Sookies!
Woah!
I know, right?
The English...
Instructions.
Thank goodness.
Suki!
Who's a good girl?
Tate!
Okay.
What
could the password be?
I can't think of anything.
Right now, unless I like...
Oh, we can go in here too!
I'm snoopin', I'm snoopin'.
He's building Metal Gear at this very moment!
Uh, nothing that I can take.
Hmm...
Nothing... that I can take.
Well, what was that article?
Maybe it's like this.
Oh, it doesn't have a date on it or anything.
Um...
Hmm...
Is there anything in the ashes now?
No?
But there's so many little details, like this being...
...off at night, things like that.
Oh, what's this?
Ghost stories of Japan!
Oh, Okiku!
Ooh...
Near the gates of Himeji Castle is an ancient well set to be haunted by the ghost of a heartbroken woman named Okiku!
Yeah, she counts in the well, you guys.
Before her death, Okiku was a beautiful servant who worked for a respected samurai.
The samurai quickly fell in love with Okiku, but she had no interest in her rich and powerful employer.
The samurai soon grew tired of Okiku's spurning of his advances and concocted a plan to win her affections.
Okiku was tricked into believing that she had broken one of the samurai's ten prized plates.
Fearing for her life, Okiku told the samurai what had happened, begging for his mercy and forgiveness.
The samurai agreed to spare her life in exchange for her love.
When Okiku refused, she was thrown into the Himeji Castle well to drown!
According to legend, Okiku's betrayal was so great and her grief so strong that her spirit cannot leave the dark confines of the well.
Well, at least not during the day.
At night, it's said that her spirit springs forth from the well and calls out...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Before being pulled back down the well by an unseen force.
The spirit's counting has led many to believe that Okiku is forever trapped in that dreadful moment when she discovered the samurai's missing plate.
Knowing that its absence would cost her life.
Some say Okiku's ghost was finally released from the well when a neighbor loudly called out, Ten!
During her nightly haunting.
Other less optimistic tellings say that her spirit is still trapped within the well, forever living out the terrible last moments of her betrayal.
Spooky.
It's like the most famous ghost story in Japan probably.
I'm scared to go in here.
Um...
I went the wrong way but that's fine.
Trying to think.
It's already 2am!
What could the past...
Also, where is William-sama?
The Yurei manga.
Oh yeah.
We haven't read that, did we?
Oh!
Whoa!
Yurei...
Lee...
Get on my nerves.
Starring Koji and Kit.
What are we doing today, Kit?
Ghost hunting.
Gulp!
Can't we just go fox hunting instead?
How many times do I have to explain why that's not funny?
Wait, are we...
So it's left to right.
It's not a real...
Manga, you guys.
Well, here we are.
Go ahead and open the door, Kit.
I'll let you get the door since you're the one with opposable thumbs.
Solicitors will be slimed?
No ghosts here!
Let's head home!
Scared, Koji.
No.
It's just that we came here...
Came to find a ghost.
And since there are no ghosts...
Hey, guys.
What's up?
Recording the sight of a haunting might actually be a really good idea.
I should look into that.
What?
What are you talking about?
Ahem.
Since there are no ghosts...
What?
I'm totally haunting this house.
We should just get back to the car and...
Okay, fine.
This house isn't haunted by just any ghost.
Ayure lives here.
Beep, beep.
That's one of those sassy but friendly ghosts that grants wishes, right?
No.
Beep.
Hehehehe.
Ayure is a vengeful spirit of a person who died tragically.
They have unfinished business to take care of before they can rest.
Just like me.
True.
I've got like a million thing...
Things on my plate right now.
We can't help the yure if we don't know why she wants revenge.
Help the yure?
You want to help a ghost?
It's for this sort of scavenger hunt I'm doing with friends.
I was ready to party!
Yipes!
Later.
More tea?
Uh, no thanks.
Tea?
Is that what this is?
I mean, yes!
More tea please!
I'll have all the tea!
Hooray for tea!
Gulp!
What the hell did that teach us?
What?
What did that teach?
What was that?
Sassy but friendly Minto.
I wish for your cutest wink.
It taught you to record the ghost.
Oh, right.
Can we use our phone for that?
Hmm.
Oh my gosh, what if you could see the ghost in here?
Wouldn't that be so scary?
Ahhhh, I still don't know.
For the computer.
I wonder if Miwako hid the password somewhere around here.
But we can't get in!
Oh, maybe here.
Uh...
No...
Oh wait, uh...
I don't think they'd have us.
Who's my favorite robotic cat?
I'd better get back to the case.
Call Bess or George?
We could do that?
It's too late to call.
Oh, I can't call right now.
Everything for the computer for now.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
Time to go to sleep.
This music is so good at being so creepy.
Okay.
Good night.
Good night, Nancy Drew.
Why can't I just sleep?
Sleep, Nancy.
Use the bed.
I guess I have to set an alarm.
Before...
7 PM.
What's happening?
Ooooooh!
What was that?
Oh, we're gonna go Jack?
Nancy...
Oh...
Ah!
Oh no!
The screen tore!
I better tell Milwaukee about this tomorrow.
I didn't expect it to...
To...
To open by itself.
It must have just been my imagination.
I should try to get some more sleep.
Am I gonna get jump scared?
No?
Okay.
Oof!
Okay...
Class dismissed!
It gets me every time.
The explosion...
Oh!
Moshi Moshi.
Hello.
Oh, hi Nancy.
What was the name of the place you're staying at again?
The Ryokan Hiei.
Told you!
Guess you're right.
What are you two talking about?
We met this girl at a bento booth at the expo, and she grew up at the Ryokan you're staying at.
Oh, cool.
Pretty crazy coincidence.
Is her name Yumi?
That's the one.
You've got to get down here and meet her.
She's so much fun.
She told us all about everyone at the Ryokan, and it sounds like you've got your hands full.
I should come to meet her.
I have a few questions.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh what?
I know that tone of voice.
Must be the wind, yeah.
What tone of voice?
Yep, that's the one.
What are you talking about?
You're working a case, aren't you?
What?
Maybe.
I don't know exactly what is going on at the Ryokan, but it's really strange.
Busted.
Okay, you got me.
I may have found a mystery.
The Ryokan.
Shocking.
So, what can we do for you?
Yeah, what's going on?
Well...
I saw something really strange in my room.
What?
A shadowy figure showed up in my room, but when I looked out on the balcony, no one was there.
It was like whoever it was just disappeared.
Creepy.
Okay, that's it.
We're leaving Japan.
I'm sure there is a logical explanation.
Me too.
I'm just not sure what it is yet.
The two of you.
I swear, if we were being chased by a dinosaur, you two would be too busy debating about the fossil record to run away.
Where is your sense of panic?
I don't think you have to leave all of Japan.
It was pretty scary, I admit.
But I don't believe that someone could just disappear.
Right.
Well, you said a shadow figure, right?
Maybe it was some sort of trick of the light.
Right.
That's what I was thinking.
I'll keep an eye out for something like that.
Spooky.
Anything else?
Oh.
Yeah, oh.
I looked in the mirror, and instead of seeing my reflection, I saw a ghostly image.
I looked in this mirror, and instead of seeing my reflection, I saw a ghostly image.
Ugh.
Creepy.
Cool.
Actually, I'm going to side with Bess on this one.
No, I've heard about stuff like this before.
There's a thing you can do to the glass to throw a false image, but it's a really fussy process.
It's hard to do without breaking the mirror.
Oh.
Yeah, the mirror broke.
So, do you think it's possible it was rigged?
It's your sleeper else's demon.
More possible than the other option.
Um, how's the expo going?
How's the expo going, George?
It's crazy.
I've never seen so many clever people in one state.
Thanks, George.
I'm definitely dealing with a little bit of that small fish, large pond anxiety.
I'm still trying to get tickets for you, but it's not looking good.
Oh, no!
That's okay.
Thanks for trying.
Have you seen the robotic cats?
Have you seen the robotic cats they have here?
They're terrifying.
I love those!
I don't know if they're cute or creepy, but I love them anyway.
Miwako has one.
It's cute, but it's a little aggressive.
Yeah.
It's in guard mode.
There's a way to override that.
Some sort of code word.
Right.
I need to figure out what it is.
Ooh.
I bet if I check around the expo, I can find someone who knows.
That would be amazing.
Awesome.
Wait.
Anytime.
Need anything else?
I'll let you go.
Talk to you later.
If all of them had the same way to disengage it, then what's the point of setting up a guard mode?
Be like, oh yeah, I know how to get rid of it.
Why would they know the password?
What time is it now?
Is there anything we have to do?
Oh yeah, that's right.
I tore one of the screens in my room.
I'm really sorry.
Do not worry, Nancy-san.
This happens often.
Very easy to fix.
Just a little steam to loosen the glue.
I'll have Lentalo take care of it immediately.
Thank you.
Thanks.
When I tore the screen, I think I saw someone on my balcony.
It's kind of bad at computer security.
Right.
It's nothing to worry about.
The screens really distort things sometimes.
I'm sure it was just your imagination.
Um...
No.
I don't think...
Maybe you're...
No.
It wasn't my imagination.
I saw someone walking on my balcony, and then she just disappeared.
You're seeing things.
It is just your imagination.
There is no war in Ba Sing Se.
She's creepy.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Bye.
Where's the convention at, I wonder?
Cause we gotta go talk to Yumi, probably.
Um, hello.
Did he even fix the mirror?
Hello?
Uh...
Is Sugi supposed to be so...protective?
Great A gaslighting.
Took a swipe at you, huh?
Oh, that's one of her mods.
Don't take it personally.
It's actually really clever.
Uh-huh.
There are these command words you say, and then Sugi changes into that mode.
She'll be protective, or aloof, or silly.
Oh, I...
Really?
Do you know the commands?
I did.
Can't remember where I put that piece of paper.
Hmm.
Okay, it's a piece of paper somewhere.
I'm back for more nonograms.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Alright, cool.
Talk to you later.
I'll talk to you later.
Catch you around.
I feel like that's really bad though, no?
Like...
What if it malfunctions and it just scratches you all the time?
Piece of paper, huh?
Maybe...
We can go see Grandma too.
Ask her about some stuff.
Grandma!
Oh, what do you have today?
Nanasi!
Today, I have a very important lesson.
We will learn origami.
Origami!
Great!
Let's get started!
Origami!
Origami has been around in many forms for centuries.
Master Yoshizawa brought the art back before it could disappear.
There is a grave danger, Nancy-san.
She gets Nancy sometimes!
If the whole world forgets a thing or a person, then it is gone.
Forever.
What do you mean by that?
Nope.
I have for you here a selection of origami patterns.
I'm gonna become- That's Nancy's next path.
A few steps away from the last step.
She becomes the origami.
You must simply match the pattern to the completed design.
Okay.
Oh!
What do you guys want to make?
Wait, what?
Oh, we match- Oh, we don't get to make it?
Aww, that's so lame.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
What is this?
So I have to figure out...
What design goes to what thing?
This is kind of weird.
I thought I was gonna fold it.
So I imagine this is that, probably.
And then this is probably that.
What?
This is weird.
This is...
Bizarre.
What?
These are...
Huh?
I can't even tell which one is supposed to be the bird.
Oh, maybe this one.
Because you fold it in half.
It's skinny.
What does this diagram mean?
Oh, wait.
Maybe like that.
Because they're supposed to be the little leggies.
Wait.
I can't tell.
This is so strange.
No.
Do it the right way.
You're not teaching me!
Oh, wait.
She's not saying anything anymore.
Hello, Nancy-san.
I'd like to try learning origami again.
I don't think I'm learning anything.
This sucks.
You're the worst teacher ever.
This is why you don't do your lessons.
So this one's probably the bird.
Then...
Do it right.
I don't remember what I did before.
Oh, no.
Is this the fish?
Probably.
Oh.
Grandma, no, Nancy!
You must read my mind!
This one, I feel like, is...
This one.
I don't understand what these steps are, though.
They are perfect.
Absolutely perfect.
You have many talents, Nancy-san.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Please visit again, Nancy-san.
Oh, now...
Oh, so there's one more activity.
Or two more, maybe.
Beginner's origami.
Okay.
Can I...
Wait.
It just teaches you about origami.
Okay.
Hi.
Mmm.
Anything in here?
No.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Okay.
I'll let you go.
Please visit again, Nancy-san.
Okay.
Oh.
Hello?
Nancy, good news.
We met Ryuichi, the creator of the Suki Cat.
What?
The thing is, he won't give away the secret phrases unless you buy one of the cats.
Oh, dang.
Alright, thanks for trying.
Well, I would hope so, because...
But then, the guy told George, for such a captivating, beautiful, gorgeous girl, he'd be willing to make an exception.
You're turning red.
Nancy, she's turning red!
Am not!
Anyway, there's a catch.
He only shares secrets with the like-minded.
No.
He gave me this monster puzzle to solve.
But I'm too busy with expo stuff to solve it right now.
Any chance that you could take a look at it?
Sure.
Anything for such a captivating, beautiful...
Enough!
I'll send it right over to you at the rear con.
Okay.
I'll talk to you later.
Talk to you later.
Cool.
How do I get it?
Uh...
Over...
Here?
Do you have it?
Hello?
Hi!
Uh...
I'll let you go.
See you later.
Where are you sending it to?
Um...
How do I get it?
Uh...
How do I...
Save?
Yeah, we'll save.
Uh...
Phone messages?
No?
Maybe in my room.
Oh yeah, maybe, maybe.
Oh...
This way.
This music is so unsettling.
It's so creepy!
Uh...
Monster...
Oh!
We have our little org army!
Uh...
What?
How do I...
Sit in my...
Suitcase?
Oh my gosh.
No...
Nancy with all her chocolate...
Has a crippling...
A crippling sugar addiction.
Eh?
Maybe the next day.
Maybe.
We'll go to sleep.
It's early, but...
Oh wait, why am I doing that?
Uh...
It's late.
I should get to bed.
Okay.
Where's that man?
I don't know.
I have no idea who that guy is.
What?
Where is it?
Nothing makes sense!
Oh, it's her boyfriend!
Wow!
What a stud!
Can't talk on my phone now.
Why not?
Shouldn't talk on my phone here.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
We'll go outside and talk.
Nancy, how's it going?
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye, Nancy!
Um...
George?
Nancy, what's up?
Where is it?
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Talk to you later.
What?
I don't know where the expo is.
So I don't know how to...
Get to them.
Is the other...
Issue.
Uh...
Wait.
Maybe it says in my room?
Because there was like a thing that's like...
The expo is happening...
At this place.
Here.
Uh...
Ah, Matsue!
Okay.
Technology of Tomorrow Expo...
Me... Matsue.
We'll go to Matsue.
Okay.
To the train, to the train, to the train...
Matsue... Matsue...
If you see it, yell, there!
If you see it, say, right there!
Matsue...
Let's see, Mutsu?
Oh!
Ah!
There!
Dave is from an older game in the series.
Got it!
Ah, let's see.
What's the easiest way to get there?
Maybe we go...
Let's see from Kure, actually.
Oh, we could go to...
Eww...
Ugh...
I don't know...
What's the easiest way?
One second, real quick...
Time to travel all over...
Japan!
For real!
Just walk...
Um...
The music disappeared...
It's...
Maybe from Fuji...
But how do I get to Fuji?
Oh, we can probably go down to...
Oh no, Tochigi doesn't...
Oh, yes it does!
Okay, let's go to Tochigi...
So, Nagoya...
Otsu, Aomori...
Kochi, Tochigi...
Okay, I won't remember that at all...
Next to Otsu...
Aomori...
Does this one...
Connect to yellow?
Okay, uh...
Kochi...
Tochigi...
Seto...
Then from there...
Uh...
Oh, wait...
Niigata!
Fuji!
This is so crazy...
Niiga!
Matsue!
Okay, but from here...
We should have a...
Be able to get to it...
Immediately, right?
Yes, okay...
We did it!
Whoa...
Robot cat...
Virtual Nyao...
Vacharu Nyao...
Lifelike movement...
Real cat noises...
Programmable commands...
Teacher cat to sit...
Stay...
Guard...
Groom...
And more...
Allergy free...
No shedding...
Oh my god...
This is...
Terrifying...
But there's nobody here...
Oh...
Bento...
I need to translate that...
It means that they are...
They are open...
For business...
See...
Guys, I sometimes...
Know Nihongo...
What is her...
Honey...
Is your name Yumi?
Absolutely not...
Who's asking?
It might be...
Are you going to order...
What's your agenda here, stranger?
I'm Nancy Drew...
Oh...
Nope.
Never heard of you...
But thank you for saying your name out loud...
Oh wait...
Nancy Drew?
As in friends with Bess and George...
And staying at the Ryok and Nancy Drew?
Or are there two of you?
Which one is it?
What is that?
That's me!
The...
Friends with Bess and George...
Excellent.
Yes, perfect.
Get over here.
Come on.
You're learning to make bento the Yumi way.
Wait, what?
Come on, trust me, it's a life skill.
Once you know how to make a good bento box, you pretty much got the whole world all figured out.
Oh, uh, uh, uh, sh-sh-sure.
Sure, sounds good.
Fantastic.
Here are the ingredients.
You may notice that they run the gamut from pretty cute to insanely adorable.
This is not an accident.
Okay, very easy.
The customers will give you a list of what they want and how they want it organized.
And you pack it together.
You won't believe how easy it is.
Oh, I see it.
Like sandwich.
Okay, I gotta go.
Going?
Where are you going?
The store.
Good luck.
You'll do fine.
What?
I'll be back soon.
Wait.
I guess I'd better get to work.
Are you kidding me?
Rabbit sandwich?
Um...
Bear...
Egg?
Bear sandwich?
Bear...
Rabbit.
Dun-dun.
Ding-ding-ding.
Wait, what's...
I don't understand.
What is...
Oh, my God.
Mucho texto.
What?!
Only three animal types are used per order.
What is this?
Wait, with this request you know the rice bear must be in the center.
This request is also three squares wide.
Compare its right column with the first request's right column.
Which has a bear... Is this like... Is this... Oh my gosh, it's...
It's Sudoku.
What?
Okay.
Uh... Okay.
So piggy here.
Right?
And then... What?
Wait, but rice rabbit is here.
Wait, what?
Am I doing this right?
Bentoku.
For real though.
I like how this is just a freaking egg.
This makes no sense to me.
I'm not gonna lie.
Maybe I... This request is also... Compare its right column with the first request's right column.
Which has a... Rabbit, bear, and blank.
With only one available spot for the pig.
This request must be the bottom row.
Combine the full request.
Rice, bear...
Pig.
With the bottom row.
Pig sandwich blank.
To find that the bottom row contains a rice pig.
A sandwich bear.
Oh, I... Oh, okay.
Ah, I think I get... Okay, hold on.
This is so... Needlessly complicated.
Okay, so this must be the rice rabbit, no?
Because it's like rice... Rice...
And the rabbit.
Rice rabbit.
I...
Think...
Wait, I'm so confused.
Rice rabbit, middle left.
Do these rotate?
Are...
Is it just in this corner?
They don't rotate.
So, bear egg.
Rice.
Maybe it's rice pig.
And rice rabbit, and then...
Pig.
Okay, okay.
I think I understand.
Okay, so...
Rice rabbit.
Pig something.
Rice pig.
Maybe it's sandwich pig.
And then bear rice.
Hey, I did it.
It was pretty cute.
Thanks for helping out, Fancy.
Rice that...
Oh.
Wow.
You bitch.
Okay, so...
Once I got it, it wasn't so bad.
But at first, I was like, What the hell?
I'm not into that sort of thing.
Couldn't you find a pamphlet?
I was hoping for an...
Insider's opinion.
She's such a weirdo!
Oh, I get it.
But you want the dirt on the situation, right?
Yes, exactly.
Interesting.
You're working some kind of anger here, aren't you?
Not that it matters.
Still, way too busy to talk.
I know you're busy, but...
I helped you out with bento.
So true.
All I want is a little information.
Okay.
For free.
Surrounded by breathtaking views, you'll not soon forget.
The Ryoka Hiei opens the door to a simpler time.
Perfect for the business traveler, hoping to experience traditional Japan, or the family in search of that perfect vacation.
Ryoka Hiei, discover Japan, discover you.
That's persuasive, but not exactly what I wanted to know.
Isn't it?
That's mine from years back.
I was thinking of going into advertising, but then I thought, nah.
I was hoping you could tell me a little about some of the strange things that have been happening.
Aha.
If you really want to know.
Oh no!
I'm running out of bento boxes.
Can you please go grab my backup stock from my apartment?
This is the sort of thing that can move us from buddies to straight up besties.
Um...
Sure.
Great.
It's just over by the Kurume station.
I could tell right away that we were going to be friends.
Here's my key.
She gave me her key?
Oh, and P.S.
My number is 075-021-5855.
What?
Uh...
So I'm guessing Miwako wants to own the Ryokan to...
either...
to...
to either keep it the way it is or to sell it.
And then Yumi doesn't want it.
And Yumi is either going to...
sell it and Miwako wants to keep it the way that it is or Yumi is like just so nonchalant and...
and...
Miwako wants to sell it.
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Maybe she'll translate the article.
Can you translate this article for me?
Okay.
Yeah, maybe she'll translate it.
How did you get this?
You know what?
I don't even want to know.
Just go put it back.
Oh, damn.
Okay.
Nancy, do you have my boxes?
Not yet.
Please hurry.
I need those boxes.
Oh, wait.
But the other questions...
Nancy, do you have my boxes?
Not yet.
Boxes, please.
This is an emergency.
I messed up.
Okay.
Where did she say her house was?
Just use Google Translate.
Right.
Um...
Oh, look at this.
Wow.
Oh, she probably needs the cat bentos, no?
Kuromi?
Transition.
Where did she say it was?
Kurume.
Kurume?
It's so far.
Oh, my gosh.
I guess we'll go back to...
Oh, hey?
Okay.
We'll go back to Fuji.
Actually, maybe we can go back home and...
Kurume.
Kurume, kurume, kurume, kurume.
From the red line.
Oh, wait.
No, we can go to Fuji.
Toyama?
No.
Because we need to go to the...
Uh...
Fuji?
Fuji to...
How do we get to the...
Oh, to Seto.
Okay.
Fuji?
Okay, let's go back to Fuji.
Teda-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta...
Niigata.
Seto.
Toyama.
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, we can go...
Kofu.
Straight to Saitama.
Wait, where do you see that, you guys?
Wait, wait.
Oh, no, Saitama, you can't, because...
Wait.
Saitama, you wouldn't be able to.
It doesn't have a pink around it.
It doesn't have a pink around it, you guys.
I wouldn't be able to transfer there.
Yes, you can.
Oh.
I want an apology from everyone who said Saitama.
What?
What is that?
Oh, her room is so cute!
I see.
Oh, I see.
Oh, wow.
Wait, did you see the eyes on this thing?
What's in here?
What are these?
What the hell is this?
I'm mega snooping, but you know what?
She deserves it.
Dear Marianne.
Oh, that was my phone!
Oh, thank you.
I'll check it.
Hold on.
I'll check it real quick.
Messages.
What the hell?
Who is that?
Who is this?
Who is this person?
Thank you, Yumi.
Dear Marianne.
As usual, these letters are piling up.
And I haven't made it to the post office.
It was great seeing you during your visit.
Hurry back soon!
I know I promised to make my way over to the States.
But life always has other plans.
The girls are keeping me busy.
And Ryokan is double booked as usual.
Yumi wanted me to tell you that she has a nice time.
Or she had a nice time during your visit.
Although, it would be hard to tell with her pouting for the cheap seats the whole time.
She and Miwako have been at each other's throats lately.
It's ugly.
I hope it's a phase, but I'm beginning to worry that it might not be.
Cassie and Ben are such good friends.
I wish I knew your secret.
They're so different.
You know, they remind me of you and me when we were kids.
You were always so serious, and I was always doing my best to get you in trouble.
I think that's what made us such good friends.
But for the two of them, it's always a battle.
Enough of that.
Send my love to the family.
I can't wait to see you again.
So-so.
So-so?
Kasume.
What the hell does that mean?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Choose shape, locate colors.
What?
What does this mean?
Huh?
What is this?
Oh!
What?
Make your own shadow puppets.
Oh-kay.
Okay.
This is probably what they did with that lady, huh?
Huh?
Like that.
Attach the paper fasteners.
Look, she's got a Wii.
But seriously, what the hell is this?
Am I supposed to see a pattern?
I don't
have the info yet?
Okay.
I want to look at this poster.
Where's the boxes?
These must be what Yumi was talking about.
Yes, I got it.
Okay.
What else?
Look at how cute her apartment is.
So stinking cute.
Aw, Mia!
Thank you so much for the break.
Thank you!
God, I am snooping.
Good thing she doesn't have her undies out.
Nancy Drew sees all.
Nancy Drew didn't take off her shoes.
What's it?
Dashcon puppet.
Okay.
Nancy!
And you've got my boxes.
Neat!
Here, I've got a thing for you.
What's that?
It's a phone charm.
You can't not have one.
I already have one.
Thanks.
What's it do?
Come to think of it, it doesn't really do anything.
Get a job, phone charm.
It probably won't.
That's okay.
Just hang it on your phone.
I've got tons.
Help me with Bento, and I'll hook you up with some super cute ones.
Okay.
Get a job, phone charm.
That's the shocker of the decade.
She's hesitant to talk to herself.
The Minto plushies.
You can talk, you can say, Get a job, Minto!
Don't go!
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
What do you think of Rantaro?
Other than that he should get a job at the Nerd Statue Factory as their primary model?
He's a good time.
What do you think of Rantaro?
Rantaro.
There's something a little weird about him.
Yeah, that weird thing about him is his personality.
That kid is his own special kind of neurotic.
Huh, always has been.
But he's my fake little brother, so I'm used to it.
Until someone brings it up, I forget how he must seem when you first meet him.
What do you mean by fake little brother?
He first moved in next door when I was seven, and Miwako was five.
He followed us around day and night.
One day, when he was being a real pain to Miwako, A real real pain?
She just snapped and punched him.
Hard.
Damn!
It was bad news.
My mother saw.
After that, we had to be nice to him no matter what.
At least when she was in sight.
Eventually, he grew on us.
Especially Miwako.
Oh, yeah, childhood friend.
Get a job, Minto.
Not me!
You have to say to the plushie, Minto.
Why do you have a book on shadow puppets?
What does Takai think of you working here?
It's a phase.
Aro snap out of it.
Like I've been hypnotized, and one day someone says the right word and snaps their fingers, and Aro go.
Heyro, I am Yumi.
One job running Ryokan, please.
She's old school like that.
Thinks the fun parts of Raif are a phase, and the nasty parts are the bees and knees.
Bees and knees.
Hello, I am Yumi.
Childhood friend angle, my weakness.
What sucks about if you like childhood friend is, like that trope, is you can only, you can't, you can't, you can't, you can't go back in time and make it possible.
You know?
Oh my gosh, I have a story though with one of my childhood friends.
I had moved, and I had my childhood friend come and stay with me for, I think it was like a week or something, when I was a kid.
And,
I was a bit of a tomboy, so I only had friends that were boys, but he came and stayed.
It was not long after, I don't know actually.
I don't know when it was.
But it was just for like, it was during summer vacation.
And so he came and stayed.
And it was.
It was the night before he left to go back home.
And we were just, we were just watching TV.
And then he gets something written on a paper, he like gets a piece of paper and is like writing on it.
And I was just like, what's, what's, what's he doing?
And I go to look at it.
And he like crumples it up and throws it away.
And he's just like, I'm gonna go to bed now.
Good night.
And I was like, okay, good night.
And maybe I shouldn't have looked at it.
because because it was a confession.
I never, I never told him that I saw it though.
I just, because I didn't, I didn't.
And I felt so bad because, because I was like, like, I didn't, I, you know, I was really young.
Neither of us could drive.
And, and my mom was really busy.
And so, she was just like, I can't, you're just gonna have to, like, hang out at the house.
And we, there was literally, like, nothing to do except watch TV.
Like, that's how it went.
And so, we were just like, we were, and, and, and, and, so, that, that was it.
That was the end of my, that, that was the, actually, after that, I never saw him again either.
After that, after that, he left and we never met again.
Are you two still friends?
No.
I, I don't know.
I don't know what that guy's up to anymore.
I don't, I've never, I haven't, I don't even, ah, yeah, I have no way to even find, talk to him, so,
I wonder why.
What do you mean?
It's not my fault.
What if I had never looked at the note?
I was being nosy.
I was being Nancy Drew.
I was like, oh, what if he drew, like, a picture?
That guy went on to write Kimi no shit.
At least you're saying accurate to the trope.
What trope?
Oh, like the childhood friends?
Yeah.
Maybe.
What, that they never get together?
Uh, so sad.
Maybe he went to jail or space or space jail.
Yeah, I should Google him.
Like, what are you up to?
My old crush is now my VTuber Oshi light novel anime adaptation.
That'd be crazy.
I don't know.
I don't know what that guy is up to anymore.
Never saw him again after that.
I don't think it was because, like, uh, because, you know, I just, I just moved really far away, so, uh, I think it was just a matter of we grew apart and I was, we couldn't meet up, so, you know.
She's your number one super chatter.
I hope not.
Uh, yeah.
I presume you would have turned him down anyway.
I don't know.
I think I was so, like,
I don't think I thought of him that way.
I mean, it was a long time ago.
Hmm.
Because it's just, like, you know, uh, all my guy friends, we were all just buddies, so.
In my, in my eyes.
But, yeah.
That's my childhood friend story.
If you, but yeah, if you like childhood friends, it's not like, uh, you know, like, if you don't keep in touch with your childhood friend, you can never have the trope happen.
So sad.
But he's home.
What do you mean I was a monster?
What did I do?
He dodged a bullet?
I agree, actually.
Your outfit is very interesting.
Where did you get it?
Get it?
Oh, you cannot get something this cool in a store.
I made it.
You make your own clothes?
Yeah.
I got sick of waiting for the boutiques to catch up to.
The places I go around here, fashion is the business.
You made us had to listen.
Oh, I've got the best thing.
You gotta have it.
I use it to come up with all of my new ideas.
What's that?
Oh, what's that?
It's a program for your phone.
You upload pictures to the computer and send them to your phone.
It lets you test out a new look on you or your friends.
It's back at my place on the computer.
Sounds great.
I don't usually have time to keep up with the latest fashion trends.
I could sort of tell, but I wasn't sure if you were going for an irony thing with your outfit.
What?
So rude!
Just teasing.
You pull off the old school thing, Nancy Drew.
Some things don't go out of style.
If you help me out with a little more bento right now, I'll hook you up with the program.
Come on.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Bear sandwich.
Bear rice.
Uh,
maybe piggy rice?
This, like, this is, because this, yeah, this would be a piggy rice.
Because, well, it doesn't have to be.
No, I mean piggy egg, sorry.
Piggy egg.
Maybe.
If I'm assuming this.
And then the bear and the pig.
It could be a, uh, wait, oh, wait, let's do this one.
I didn't, uh, piggy rice?
Or it could be middle.
Eh,
sandwiches are in the middle row.
How do you know?
Oh, I see.
Oh, wait, this has to be the, yeah.
Wait, I just remember.
Oh, realize.
Because, if I do this, then we can't do this.
So, this is this, and then this is, wait, huh?
Wait.
See, so if I do this, with sandwich, it wouldn't make sense for this square.
Um, yeah, we wouldn't be able to do this square.
So, it has to be down here.
And then the sandwich here.
Right?
And, eggy, eggy.
So, this is a sandwich.
And then piggy rice.
Can be here or here.
And it could be cat, cat.
No, it can't be cat, cat.
Cat.
Wait, but that would make it, oh no, cat sandwich.
then maybe cat rice.
Piggy, egg.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Oh,
put double sandwich.
Yeah.
Oh, you're right.
Ah, ah, I like, I don't mind this one not as much.
It's a little more challenging, so it's fun.
So, this would have to be, but it can't be the middle either.
Because it wouldn't be able to be two cats.
Unless it's like this.
wait a second, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, hold on.
So, if this is sandwich, no.
Then, like this, could be the sandwich, sandwich.
So, sandwich, and then the sandwich.
This is another sandwich.
I'm just going to put a piggy sandwich.
So that we know.
Piggy rise.
But then, piggy egg, could go down here.
Wait, no.
Because, wait.
Oh, it's the cat cat.
Yeah, wait, this works, this works.
So let's say, let's just cat, cat.
And then this is two eggs.
Oh!
Does it work?
Wait, what's, what's wrong?
Oh, wait.
All right.
Yeah!
Who's next?
Step right up.
Great job.
Yeah!
There you go, Nancy.
See?
thank you.
Love that last picture you sent.
I know, isn't that one great?
Okay, why do you have a book?
Why do you have a book on shadow puppets?
Oh, that's Miwaku.
See?
It shouldn't be in my apartment.
It's just a stupid book about puppets.
It's just another one of the things that my grandmother is trying to auto-waste push on us.
Could you use something like this to make spooky shadows from far away?
It's totally Miwaku.
Yeah, I guess.
It's totally Miwaku!
I met your sister Miwaku.
You two seem pretty close.
That doesn't sound like the impression you'd get by having a chat with Miwaku.
What are you trying to ask?
Miwaku seemed a little upset about the Ryokan.
Do you know anything about that?
That's more her area of expertise.
I've never been the go-to guru for the Ryoka.
Guru.
That place is the definition of repetitive.
Guests come in, guests come out.
It's brain-breakingly tedious.
I don't know how Miwaku puts up with it.
Okay.
Does Miwaku like working at the Ryokan?
Well, yeah.
I'm gonna give her the other one.
Why Alice would she be there day in and day out?
I don't wanna give her my way.
What that girl needs is to spend some time out here.
A few weeks with me and my friends would be enough to shake her up and get her to have some fun for once.
Hmm.
Would you like a phone charm?
Oh!
I could give her back to Oniki.
Cute, thanks.
So, you don't wanna take over the Ryokan?
Oops.
Not even for a second.
I mean, I don't even get the whole tradition thing.
You wanna go to the past?
Get a time machine.
I'm not one for living in the past.
You're wacko.
Have you ever read a history book?
The past is where we keep all of the terrible things that have happened.
Another pronunciation of Ryokan.
I know.
Mr. Smovington, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
If you're the one who's supposed to take over the Ria Khan, why is Miwako the one working there?
Ugh, Nancy-chan.
Don't get everyone else on me here.
If I had known I was supposed to run that place when I grew up, I would have taken a pass on the whole Firstborn thing.
If Miwako left the Ria Khan, who would run it?
I don't know.
It doesn't matter.
Why do you care so much about it anyway?
I'm just sort of naturally curious.
I'd back burner that curiosity as long as you're staying at the Ria Khan if I were you.
What do you mean?
Try not to find out.
Okay, Nancy?
You seem nice.
Oh, that's kind of...
Hello.
Can you tell me a little bit about what happened with your mother?
This is not the time or the place.
Is there a better time?
Maybe when you're not at work?
There is never going to be a time or place.
Just drop it.
Place.
Nancy-chan.
Can you come back in a bit?
Hold on.
Oh, okay.
Let's go to her house then.
I was going to ask to do more bento so we can try and get another thing.
Wait, what does that say?
Oh, Chika Tetsuno Eki.
What?
Ah, she's in Kurume.
I made her mad.
I think I did.
It's okay.
She'll love me later.
And we'll get more things for the avatar.
Oh, whoops.
I just kept her keys?
Okay.
At least I remembered to lock up.
Okay, so we are trying to get...
This piece...
Down here with blue...
Two blues in the corner.
And a blue up top.
Like, blue up top.
Blue up top.
Blue in the corner.
Uh...
No, not that...
Corner.
This hurts my eyes.
Oh, it's so...
Oh, this one?
Oh, no.
Oh, the wrong corner.
My bad.
What kind of game even is this?
It's so horrible.
Who designed this?
Yeah!
Enter phone number to send avatar.
Choose a model.
Start!
Oh my god!
Wait, I'm gonna make...
Wow!
Woo!
They're different colors.
Wait.
It was rainbow.
What happened to it?
Oh, it's rainbow on this one.
Oh!
Holy...
Wait, can we do Seifuku?
Oh, come on.
Seifuku is like the standard outfit.
Please!
What?!
We have a child...
Oh no!
We can...
This is horrendous.
What the hell is that?
What?
Oh, head.
What do you think of my anime character desu?
You're so cute.
We have a snake on our arm.
Oh, this is actually pretty moe.
Let's change the hair.
Kawaii!
Nancy-chan!
Nancy-chan, kawaii!
Kawaii!
There we go.
I think this is good.
I almost thought it said yabai for a glance.
I was about to be like, no way, yabai.
The ubu is strong with this one.
Cool math game splash core.
Wait, who can I...oh wait, I need a phone number.
5-2-3-5-5-5-8-7-3-3.
Can you guys remember that?
5-2-3.
What was the last bit?
8-7-3-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-6-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-5-6-6-5-6-5-5-5-6-5-5-5?
Ding!
I wonder why.
We got her phone number, too.
Right?
Yumi.
Can't call until I'm finished.
I can make a call later.
Do they call her Nancy Drew because Nancy is an artist?
Clearly.
Oh, I sent it to Bess.
I did?
Yeah, I clicked Bess.
I clicked Bess.
Send it to yourself.
I don't know what my number is.
Don't you gotta send it to yourself?
What's my number?
That's standard in non-Nancy Japan, Minto-chan.
This is the Japan where Ryokan's, this is Japan where Ryokan's where you learn origami, true!
I'm a fool.
Wait, let's make another one.
What if I pick no body?
It's just a shadow person.
Kawaii.
These are so ugly.
Oh, Lolita Desu!
Oh, so...
So beautiful.
Lolita?
Oh...
Lolita Desu?
I'll go with this one instead.
Wait.
I guess she's just a shadow person.
Sugoi!
I did it!
Like your friend in the hotel room.
So true!
Oh, it does kind of look like Peach, huh?
What's wrong?
Oh.
Way to make a style in Avatar.
Phone fashion software is here to keep your whole contact list looking fashionably fly.
See you on the runway.
Oh, gosh.
Yumi jumpscare.
Fashionably fly.
Woo!
This game is kind of dating itself, huh?
What is this?
So that's one...
Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Okay.
Madam Butterfly.
Hmm.
I want to make this Avatar.
Okay, guys.
I think I'm gonna call it quits for here today.
This is good fun.
This song is driving me insane, actually.
Okay.
I have a delivery for you.
Oh!
Oh, she's got it!
Nancy Drew.
Thanks.
Um, wait.
Uh.
Oh, gosh.
There's so much.
There's so much here.
Okay, hold on.
I'll let you get back to work.
Okay, see ya.
Wait, this is, uh...
This is what we were waiting for.
Oh, that's not it.
The package.
Where is it?
This one?
Wow.
George wasn't kidding.
This does look hard.
Oh.
No, no way.
Why couldn't it be a doodle grab?
Oh, but you do it in sections.
No.
This is so messed.
Why?
But I love the nonogram muscles.
Okay.
Uh.
We will...
We will do this next time.
Not right now.
So I'm gonna save.
Me too.
Don't laugh.
Why are you laughing?
Actually, before we do...
One last nonogram.
Never mind.
I've never done a 20 by 20 nonogram before.
I've never done one.
We will do it next time.
Thank you guys for Nancy Drew.
With me.
This was a lot of fun.
Um.
And...
Yeah.
It's already been almost five hours.
So...
I'm getting sleepy.
I hope...
You haunt the person that made that...
That streamwire puzzle.
I will.
Thank you guys.
Oh wait.
Let me lick my ghostly part.
I'm in the...
I'm in the haunted...
My god.
I slept in the middle.
Good.
I'm glad.
Oh.
Hi dog.
Thanks, dry princess.
My throat's a little sore.
Today.
And I'm sleepy.
Yippee.
Ha.
Wait.
Do I...
Do I stream tomorrow?
I can't remember what days I took off.
Oh.
I have tomorrow off.
Yippee.
Rugamesh.
Sorry for crashing the line.
I tried to run from the mid-cafe to make it.
I'll be sure to be early next time.
No.
You're all good.
Rugamesh.
All good.
I have no stream tomorrow.
But I have other things to work on.
So I have...
I will be busy busy.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Actually, I have lots to do tomorrow.
Otsumito.
And thank you guys.
Bye.
For Nancy Drew.
I guess we can...
Finish this.
Maybe.
Next week.
I don't...
Let's see.
How long to beat Nancy Drew?
Which...
Which is Shadow...
Something.
Shadow at the water's edge.
About eight and a half hours.
I think we got this.
I'm a little slow though.
Because I...
Like to just chit-chat.
And stuff.
Okay.
Thank you guys for watching.
And I hope you guys have a great day.
Have a great night.
And I'll see you next when I...
See you.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Ending screen birthday song.